This episode of Your Mom's house is brought to you by Saatva luxury mattress.
The only online mattress company that provides free delivery set up and mattress
removal.
Christina.
Good Morning Julia.
Alright,
here we are back for another episode of Your Mom's house.
Palm Guy.
It's a big day here,
Jean.
Huge Day.
First of all,
my Netflix,
a half hour on the degenerates premiers and today actually it'll be yesterday by
talking to this October 30th it's ready.
I am number six on the lineup.
Joey Diaz is right before me so you can catch your two phase.
But check out the degenerates on Netflix.
And also I am proud to announce that I am also Paulie and by Yup.
And did you tell your parents about it?
I got to tell everybody about that.
Also.
I'm announcing a tour 2019 and it's called the ride or die tour.
Ratable.
Okay.
You guys are doing good.
So First San Diego,
November 24 at the second show,
10:00 PM almost sold out.
Get your tickets,
fill her up.
Delphia second show also,
that one's going fast.
December 7th,
uh,
and then December 8th Jude Dork titties.
That lay show is just about gone in June.
Dork Katie's at the Gramercy theater.
All right,
here we go.
2019 January 10th at the comedy store in the main room here in Hollywood,
California.
And then I go January 31st if February,
Psychic Denver,
Colorado at the comedy works.
February 28th to March 2nd Madison,
Wisconsin,
the comedy club on state April four through six mini apple tits.
Acme comedy club.
That's the first time I'm ever doing that one.
So I'm super excited to go there.
May 10th and 11th Tempe at the Improv and June 20th to 22nd Washington deck.
Come at the Dick come m prob.
So that's just the first six months of the tour.
And I know y'all asked me to give you a lot of times so you can come to all of
these.
This is my big ass club tour and must small theater tour.
That's right.
There you go.
Christina p online for tickets.
Jean Jane,
a huge shout out.
Thanks everybody that came to shows in Fresno and Bakersfield.
I had a blast.
I did not know.
I would have such a good time.
And I did.
I appreciate you guys this week.
There's very,
very few tickets left.
Um,
a hundred or so in fort
and a hundred in Augusta,
Georgia,
Jacksonville and Orlando are sold out.
He said all of the names wrong.
Montclair is completely sold out,
both shows in New Jersey.
I fill her up.
Delphia,
um,
has tickets to the late show on Friday,
November 16th.
And here's what I got for you for a,
the take it down to her.
You've got to Thomas [inaudible] dot com slash tour.
You can see all the dates you've been adding shows all over the place,
including the first added show January 4th in San Francisco.
But excuse me,
the two most recent ads,
uh,
we added them today are Madison,
Wisconsin,
April 11th.
We're adding a late show and we are adding a,
another show before that,
uh,
February 16th and Cleveland gave Lung Chemo is French,
Ohio.
Thank you so much to both of those cities.
Uh,
the demand has merited second shows there as well.
And I've had shows all over the country.
So not for people that keep and continuously mentioned cities that I have not
just announced.
Um,
I'm telling you they're going to come.
I'm going to do a probably a,
a couple months into the new year,
I will announce the second half of 2019.
I appreciate you asking me about it.
It'll be all over Canada.
It'll be all the U s cities that you're wondering why I'm not hitting.
They're all going to be there.
Let's get into some good stuff,
Jean.
We have incredible clips.
We have an incredible guest.
It's going to be really a lot of fun today.
Where is,
here we go.
Here's our first one.
Let's do it.
Are you ready gene,
where you get into this?
Let's start.
Make sure that this is ready to go.
Here we go.
It's five residential.
Got It.
Hey,
fuck you.
Both of you.
25,
25 residential.
Fuck you both.
Oh was right.
I don't bring anyone loving to them.
Well,
we'll go to your mom's house.
Big Fan of this lady.
We're going to notice in a second before I forget.
Um,
I went to,
uh,
just remind people that they'll see something unusual,
whether they're watching or listening.
This week we're going to tack on,
we had an opportunity to sit with Kate from below deck,
so I love her so much.
When the episode appears to be about to end,
we're going to smack on a real talk segment.
Real talk for the new listeners is we used to really talk about a lot of reality
shows a lot and uh,
it's one of our first segments and we had the great opportunity to have her here
in studio.
So we talked to her for quite awhile.
It's below deck on Bravo.
We've talked about the show before.
We love it.
Yeah,
well you know we fell in love with Kate from the minute
we saw her cause her whole thing is,
she's the chief stewardess.
She was two and she has resting bitch face and she's fucking fantastic and
you're going to love the interview.
We learned all about the yachting world and you'll never guess how much it cost
to charter a yacht for a week.
I think it's a really fascinating conversation with a really fun,
funny,
interesting lady.
She's great.
Um,
there's that.
So this lady not,
this is not Kate,
this is not,
I mean they look mad the same.
So this lady is,
I love this woman too though.
I love her spirit.
Identify with her actions.
So do I.
I mean,
it's really unnerving when you're on a nice walk with your dog or your child and
you see someone's speeding.
Damn a man.
She's a little heated,
but you know it happens.
Fuck you.
25,
25 residential.
I feel this way every time.
A motherfucker spots on our street,
don't you?
Of course I hated,
I am inches away from being this woman right now.
I've talked to the police department about the speeding.
Yeah.
Good for you.
I also can't wait until I'm this age when like menopause is officially over and
I'm no longer a woman and shut shut,
stopped wearing a bra put on just sweatpants all day,
every day.
Ratty ass sneakers,
the where's Waldo shirt and get that butch haircut.
Dude.
I'm all about it.
You're ready for it.
And a sporty watch to digital digital locks
there.
I got the sweatshirt on already.
We are only priority is giving your dog a high quality of life.
That's it.
Are you serious?
I'm serious.
Goddamn residential neighborhood.
25 up the hill.
25 don't you understand?
Chill out yourself,
asshole.
I love her.
Can we hire her?
Can we hire her to stand on our street and do that?
Wouldn't you love it?
I would love it.
That's such a good idea.
Give her a megaphone though.
So it projects 25 asshole.
Always.
They're like,
as people are driving,
you just,
you just hear things.
People are looking around,
hey,
fuck you.
Both of you.
It's pretty great.
You know there's something about women when you take out the instinct to attract
a man,
when that instinct is either gone through nature,
stopping your mensies or by being a lesbian,
like those women are like super women.
I just love them so much.
When you don't give a shit,
if guys like your energy,
it changes.
It's so funny,
Dude.
It's,
it's just the best.
My energy did it
by the way.
There's another,
uh,
when I stopped caring what you're saying.
Yeah.
No one I stopped caring about male,
male.
Attention,
attention.
People,
uh,
are following closely sober.
October.
I know.
And the uh,
Ari gets posted and the shit crazy workout.
I just saw it on Instagram.
I saw it is,
yeah.
The,
he racked you.
Yeah,
but guess what,
what?
I didn't upload my workout from Yellowstone,
so have no fear guys.
I can't believe how many people thought it would let them down.
There were none of us are going to win because Joe's too far in the lead.
He's going to win,
but I promise you is that I won't come in last.
Well that's the shame spot.
That's the shame spot.
That's really the only thing.
This sober October,
that's the goal is to just not be last.
Can't be less because Joe is going to be number one.
Abi.
Yeah.
Bart's gonna on the at the 11th hour.
Like,
like,
yeah.
Joe Or Bert.
Yeah.
Bert.
He's going to be up at like midnight.
No latch.
You have a cutoff time.
When's the cutoff?
The cutoff time is 7:00 PM Pacific 10 eastern on October 31st
wow.
Yup.
You think Bart's been sober this whole time?
Um,
I do.
I do think he's been sober this whole time.
I really wish we could've had the bracelet.
I know I would have been so funny.
And surveys called scram or something
or we would get alerts if alcohol interdis system humiliating.
I know.
It'd be so funny we put the word out now.
Maybe in one year's time somebody can donate that to the cause.
Is there anybody listening that has a scram bracelet they could donate to sober
October.
Androids of dot.
That's what I'm saying.
That's why I'm putting a call out now.
We have one year.
Someone who's affiliated with it will show up.
All right.
Anyways,
here we go.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Figure it out.
I hope you get a Goddamn fucking citation for $1 million.
You both pieces.
Her dog is really chill for having such a fired up owner.
Well,
she's in control of him.
She's in control dude of life,
Huh?
Yes.
Dammit.
Yeah.
Okay.
He had a speeding ticket.
Fuck head.
My mom would do that all the time.
It made me laugh a lot.
She,
one time she marked a woman who was fake,
her crying.
She was like,
well,
they're finding a parking spot.
And she was like,
oh,
are you going to cry?
Was so crazy like this.
Oh my God,
this chick's way funnier.
But she's at fired up about other stuff though.
Well sure.
It's misdirected.
Ain't,
yeah,
it's always like when you're this angry,
I mean God damn.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
That's a little too far.
This is mental.
Yeah.
This might be drunk on a segment.
She definitely needs a better haircut.
Needs a new haircut.
And then she went from a really funny,
too low.
Scary.
Let them go overboard.
It was hilarious.
And then there's bending and then there's breaking and yeah,
she's got that Lloyd Christmas haircut.
The short banks.
That should never looks good dude.
Like the short version probably will.
This never looks good.
She probably watched people speed for like years and these are the first people
that should realize that she can yell at like this.
Okay,
I'm crossing a street by my God damn dog leashes.
I Shit,
she's not wearing her bra.
She looks up.
No,
I just saw the her nips waves ones.
Yeah,
like mine.
It hurts her hanging low.
She has a better bra.
I would like this.
You don't know where else I would like her on the speaker at the grocery store.
Yeah.
It's really back up.
You know when people start taking their time,
trader Joe's parking lot,
when that motherfucker who's in the parking spot and they're not backing out
immediately.
Yup.
Whoever's checking their email,
sitting in the parking spot,
go,
dude,
I agree.
If two seconds go,
fuck
yeah,
still talking.
They're driving away and she's still,
that's when you know you're really fired up.
Yeah.
Can I ruined her whole day?
That was really something that was really,
Shit.
Life is so magical,
isn't it?
It is a really fascinating,
I can see myself going down that path.
Like,
let's say I'm a widow,
you die and I'm that age and I'm not getting with other dudes.
Kids are grown.
It's just me and the five dogs,
five dogs,
and maybe we're speeding.
Speeding.
And all I have is his house,
fucking mother fuckers.
All I have is my property.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
And then these disrespectful punks parked that they were probably speeding.
They weren't.
They were.
They all do,
dude.
These kids in your Mustang.
I don't
know what this is here it says the diarrhea challenge.
Oh,
my wife refuses to eat my ass because she thinks it's gross.
Yeah,
of course.
However,
she has agreed to what I'm calling the no diarrhea challenge or if I can go 90
days without having diarrhea,
she will try it out and eat my ass for a full two minutes.
Problem is,
I can't go more than 72 hours without my be whole doing an impersonation of the
chocolate fountain.
That was at my sister's wedding.
Any advice?
Yeah,
man.
I mean I really am pulling for you here,
but I think number one,
it's pretty obvious.
You need to change your diet dramatically.
See a doctor,
you go see a doctor,
but make,
make diet changes for it.
You might be able to solve it on your own.
All rights.
Ibs,
because our dog was having bouts of diarrhea.
The first thing to check is,
is your diet.
Check that diet.
You might be all right.
He might be lactose intolerant.
Yeah.
Or he just might be having like high fat or high five.
You know,
you just got to,
you gotta figure out what you're eating and maybe changing it.
Well,
like when I eliminated sugar,
my dumps changed dramatically.
Yeah,
you're very sensitive to sugar and fried foods.
Think if we have a role at Sushi and it's,
there's fried in it,
you get diarrhea immediately and then you're like,
I'm not eating it tonight.
Um,
oh,
I never eat your,
but for this,
especially those nights for the record,
for the record,
those nights you're like,
no,
not anymore.
Never did.
Not Anymore.
This is a,
Oh,
this was our,
I know we had our discussion about the numbers of money and Cooper k person.
Yeah,
something like that.
Conrad Conrad.
The lesson to remind people,
the discussion was about how they were going to about to go out one night and
the guy reminded the girl,
he who he had just started dating a few weeks ago that she still owed him 50
bucks and it created this very uncomfortable argument.
Eventually basically led to them falling apart.
Yeah,
so here is a an email about that.
I was listening to your podcast this week.
Enjoy your discussion about the age gap.
Couple on below deck in a variable that stuck out to me was that the gift in
question was a carton of cigarettes.
The guy might not support hand has habit of smoking and not want to enable to a
certain extent.
For me,
I'd eat the 50 bucks if it was dinner clothes,
but not cancer sticks.
However,
I'm not as European as he's boat employees.
I also have not seen this season,
so maybe they both smoke.
I love to hear your thoughts,
grace.
Yeah,
they do.
Actually both too.
They both smoked,
but that was an interesting thought on her part.
Then maybe he was a kind of whenever.
Yeah,
no he wasn't.
He wanted to see much back.
Yeah,
he went his 50 bucks.
Poor I should say.
Um,
I mean,
I don't know the working guy and he's not poor,
but when you were 21 or 2150 bucks is like,
but poor implies basically unemployed and get buy in a box.
And was,
he was being cheap.
That's true.
Um,
look,
it's a real exciting day.
Let's just celebrate it.
Okay.
Maybe you know me.
History.
She didn't husband.
I'm saying today is the day summary.
It's the queen's birthday.
So I'm taking over all our socials,
asking you to post Hashtag happy birthday Tricia.
Hey,
there's some cakes,
cupcakes,
but your favorite meal.
All she knows you like.
Okay.
And she loves you.
I love you.
Thank you.
Oh yeah.
He's probably like you.
Who the fuck lit though?
Right?
Okay.
Can't tell you how great.
A weekend that was started in Portland.
They were to Dallas now home to Nashville for some sleep.
We had a wonderful time.
Love you guys.
Thank you for everything.
Everything.
Can we start with the first one?
Yeah,
sure.
No,
I,
here's the thing to the casual observer and,
and I've been reposting these on Instagram and I read the comments and some
people are like,
what a psycho dead behind the eyes.
I hundred percent crazy.
And then there's the odd ball who's like,
well,
what's wrong with Garth?
He seemed super nice and you're like,
you're missing the point.
But that's,
you're missing it person though that likes cats.
Yeah.
You can't explain someone like that.
There's like people who get it and then don't.
Yeah,
no,
I,
I know I posted his stuff.
Yeah.
I mean it was 90% like what?
Fucking bloodthirsty maniac and six people were like,
how dare you?
He's a saint.
I didn't believe that.
You don't,
you know,
like he's the greatest.
Well,
there's no debate.
Listen,
we're not debating.
This man is talented.
He's so talented and he's so successful and,
and he's beloved by many.
There's no question about that.
However,
I feel like he's being disingenuous when he does the social media posts because
why he's,
he's not being him.
And you can tell it reads so false.
Know why he's not.
Because he's a demon on the and side.
It's right.
He has a demon on the insight and he also darknesses there.
He's so removed from regular people.
Yes.
And he's been so famous.
First of all.
Yes.
I know you're famous,
but so famous.
Yes.
For so long did he has no idea.
No,
no idea how to connect with like he,
he's imagining like the,
the guy at the gas station,
he was like,
hey Garth.
And he's like,
I got to talk to that guy.
And he's always right.
Big smiles are waves.
And
I remember me,
I'm big fan.
I liked that you guys are fans too.
I'm a fan of you
and of you.
Well he's faking sincerity and mostly he's faking being humble.
And I think that's what reads to me.
Like come on now,
like you're faking and also the shit about,
I'm Mr Yearwood here.
I'll Mr Yearwood,
which is so fucking condescending to the wife.
It's so fucking condensate,
like first of all,
your fame level
is just stratosphere.
Like you're the top of the top of the food chain of showbusiness.
Dude.
Nobody rivals scarf,
I think in terms of like,
like he's amazing.
Yeah.
So for him to be like,
ah,
I'm just a humble pie,
Mr here,
I'm misery.
It's bold.
Well,
he has a triple digit body count and we don't know how many people he's killed.
Oh.
And I,
I feel like,
yeah.
Game recognize game cigarettes.
You dig up plots of land on his ranch.
Yeah.
It's just mass graves.
We're crazy.
Train.
Yeah,
for sure.
Maybe not that,
but maybe he's really mean behind closed doors.
Oh,
I see it.
Remember what he did?
His happy birthday to G.
Oh yeah.
What's this?
What the fuck is it?
He's like,
yeah,
yeah.
Uh,
Yeah.
Somebody interrupted him and he about lost his marbles.
But what I find really condescending.
Yeah.
It's like,
ha ha ha,
ha.
Mystery Hashtag happy Hashtag Mr Yearwood every,
I took over her socials for today.
Everybody seeing her a picture cake.
Like what?
Yeah.
What are you just press stop.
Stop it.
People can like your music without having to think you're this guy,
right?
I got it.
Oh there he is.
There he is.
It's,
it's supposed to happen.
The rage.
The quiet.
Yeah.
He was about fucking slit.
Somebody's the quiet rage.
See thing.
Look at that.
Is that supposed to happen?
Me
Happy Birthday.
Lever to g happy birthday to gee.
Do you think he said that to him on his birthday?
Does he go through it and he's like,
yeah,
birthday to g.
Me Jane.
He makes his staff is do things.
He makes a staff stand and like clap for him and shit when he comes in.
I bet you got it.
Don't look at me policy.
Don't look at me.
Maybe you know me.
History.
She didn't.
What's husband?
He is the day.
So it's the queen's birthday.
The Queen's birthday association asking you to post Hashtag happy birthday
Tricia.
I mean that country music is so weird though.
Yeah,
that's fucking Weirdos,
man.
It is all that insincere bullshit.
Light will come on.
Y'All can stay at our house.
If it let me know if you ever need anything,
which is all bullshit.
Yeah.
That's the part of it that's just so hard to,
to click with,
cause they're just none of that.
I never bought into any of that when I lived in Florida,
Carolina,
all that like,
but we're just real neighborly.
No,
you're not.
You're not because I don't know.
I can't speak from experience.
I know.
I feel like,
I feel like a lot of people are nice,
a lot of people are friendly,
but people overstate how,
uh,
what they are actually willing to do and what they like,
what level of a friendly they're trying to,
and there's a lot
of masking,
a real race.
Sure.
An emotional,
you know what it is because it's unacceptable to be mean or angry in that
culture.
So everything's kind of backhanded,
like the,
bless her heart when the women are like,
well bless her heart.
That's code for fuck you bitch.
You know.
Oh Hey.
Well,
just bless her heart.
That's really passive aggressive to say on your birthday.
I'm definitely going to have people send photos of digital cakes and their
favorite meals.
This virtual shots and cakes,
cupcakes,
favorite meal waiver.
She knows you love her.
Okay.
She loves you.
I love you thing.
What the fuck was that?
Dang.
What the fuck?
Turn your goddamn phone off when you're recording me.
You piece of Shit and you will notice that Tricia gets larger every year.
She's with Garth.
I know.
No,
it's not the fat thing.
It's that she's clearly not dealing with some feelings and I think it's because
of Garth.
Garth has to be unbearable.
Just unbearable.
It's so condescending.
Like why can't it's anyway.
It's hard to be Mr Yearwood.
Mr Yearwood.
How fucking bullshit.
Can I tell you to any self respecting male would,
would you ever be like,
he know how I'm just Mr Pudge,
if
I was to be to see,
she did a great job on her degenerates.
Make sure she knows you love her.
Yeah.
Okay.
Yeah,
sure.
Tell.
Tell him what to thank Tom.
You got God.
You know Ms. Mr p I think he's just,
I also maybe part of it is his age and not coming up in the digital era.
I get that and like doesn't know how to make a video.
No,
partially that it's that he probably has like a fucking team come in just to
make that kind of shit.
Oh yeah.
Cause he,
he doesn't understand how this is done at all.
They should have made him watch a few peoples casual videos and then like you
just talk to people casually.
You don't have to rehearse in your head what you're going to say.
It does.
Hashtag happy Hashtag Hash tag tag you're it and you're like said,
I guess Manny Hashtag Music Hashtag Hashtag your it
why are you at?
That's not part of the culture at all.
You're it,
you're the tit tag.
You're it.
That's what he means.
Expert in this house.
Here's an a question.
Do your is my best friend and I are the opposite ends of the tip vagina
spectrum.
Okay.
We need your advice on what society deems the most desirable private part.
Disposition.
She's a double d s l u t with dark brown nips.
Well,
my handfuls tail is a door with light pink pokers blessed in our fruit.
However,
we argue about society's nipple hierarchy.
What is better pink or Brown?
She also has commented on that my high
and tight clamshell is more desirable than her triple layer puffy Taco home
here.
Now,
Marissa,
by the way,
you're now a woman's email.
Yes.
I love it.
Well,
I'll tell you,
coming from somebody that's had both colors,
a brie children,
I had a bank.
Now they're brown and purposely,
no.
Huh?
I mean I'm not a guy.
So you tell me Tommy,
I honestly feel like I,
I kind of like,
I'm darker now cause before they,
I'm very pale under here.
Very Alabaster,
so to have like light pink ones.
It was like I had no nips.
Yeah.
But now they're gigantic and they really are.
They stand out because of the color difference.
And I don't,
I like it.
I think to change anything
buddy,
that really,
like if you're,
if a guys are really serious about their opinion on this,
it's kind of,
it's kind of bullshit because like as long as there's Teddy's that you could
smack and squeeze and squishing it down and hit stable,
you can slice and do whatever you want to write.
I don't care about colors.
Same thing.
Like she seems to have a real nice poon on her,
right?
She's got a nice high end tie.
Clamshell and her friends got a triple layer puffy taco.
But my thing is I could slide into either one.
Yeah.
Right.
So,
yeah,
I mean maybe hers looks more appealing.
Right.
At the end of the day,
I'm going to wear both like a surgeon,
the Basque,
and I'm just going to finish what I finish,
you know?
Yeah.
And I kind of wish,
um,
I used to have a bit about this that I stopped doing,
but I kind of wish women would stop torturing themselves with weight,
with looks and with things of this nature.
Like my vagina's a little sloppier looking than I've learned to,
to just tortured Trisha Yearwood on her weight though.
Yeah,
but that's different.
That's because I think she's in an emotional crisis.
I think it's about,
it's not about the wage.
Do you think because she's held hostage?
Yeah.
I think she fucking hates his guts and she's eating her feelings.
That's what I think is going on.
So that's unhealthy.
But I'm talking about with the girls that are like,
guys only like it when we're skinny.
Guys only will like me if I'm this weight.
Here's the truth that I've learned.
Yeah.
There's a guy out there who's going to love whatever it is you're offering.
The straight ones.
The real dudes.
Yeah.
Don't give a fuck.
They don't care about color of nipples.
Don't care.
Really about the appearance of your posts.
They just want to know that you're letting them in there.
Right?
So it's don't even think about this nonsense.
Younger girls,
because guys don't care.
It's very true.
They just want you to love them.
And like,
there'll be holes,
which I'm waiting on
waiting on every day.
Never.
You want to step in and see,
uh,
your lady here,
your friend,
your bestie.
Yeah.
To my [inaudible] had been cheated on by their men.
Snatch your phone.
Stop making it your fault to my kings up there that had been cheated on by their
stop making it your fault.
Yes.
Women she to then use the other thing,
sex is one of the strongest forces in the universe that we have to deal with.
This is about self mastery.
It's not even about what's going on in the relationship.
Okay.
So if you think just because somebody says they love you or you think just
because they want to be in a relationship with you,
that that means that that's going to dissolve all their traumas that they come
with.
You know what I'm saying?
And that they're going to know how to deal with their traumas.
Ah.
People gone mess up.
I really liked that.
She's so pretty.
She's very pretty.
Yes.
My kings and Queens.
So you've got to find someone who's worth it.
Self masturbation.
Oh,
let me see as our guest here,
she's talking about masturbating,
Tom.
Oh,
studio g's all over the place.
We a day.
Okay.
Let's take a quick break and we're back and we are here with our guest who is a
comedienne.
Okay.
What is that?
Is Star of some multiple television shows?
A writer,
producer,
director,
I mean
rapper,
choreographer,
she film star
does it all.
It is Ms. Whitney Cummings,
what's your pronoun?
Do we say comic or comedian?
I would say I still always does that
comic,
but whenever there's a female I like to make a big
point that,
and I would just say Comedienne lady come lady comic comedian.
Like what old school guys will say to make sure that
the disclosure,
there's two,
I'm not going to say who they ride with.
Carbon Rom.
Um,
guys an nd when you do their show,
they're Lego lady comedian.
And it's so like when I first started standing up and probably still like up
until a couple of years ago when someone would,
you know,
the comedy store is just kind of like bring up other comics and then what is it
my turn to go out of?
I'm sure there's avenues.
Like are you guys ready for a lady?
What does that even mean?
And then it just cues everyone to get up to go to the bathroom.
Oh God.
There's also that thing where you get brought up,
you know,
no one ever brings me up as lovely.
It is gorgeous.
Lovely lady.
Lovely guy.
He's so handsome.
There was one time Tommy and I did a gig together when we were like year seven
and stand up and we showed up together.
We were both performing that night and the booker goes to me,
you're a comedian.
And Tom to his credit stands up for me.
And he goes,
Jesus man,
what is this?
The 1950s and you busted his balls.
And I was like,
wow,
that was so,
it happens so much to me that was like,
I didn't,
I was in Houston,
I guess this was like eight,
nine years ago.
It was Tom Arnold was doing standup I guess at the time.
And he asked me and Dalea to go with them and we went and did like he hosted and
we did stand up and the booker when I went on stage,
smack my ass like,
like hurt.
Chris Thought Chris was there.
He saw and I started laughing because I just was like,
hey,
like I didn't even know what to do.
I like,
it was just like,
I don't have time to even process how screwed up this is.
Like I just was like,
Hey,
and like my butt,
like horror and stung because I had like rug burn on my bud hall and I was like,
this is insane.
And then I just remembered it like a year ago and I was like,
that was fucked up.
I know.
You remember in hindsight,
do that too.
You know,
male booker would smack your ass.
Um,
we'd love Chris Taleah by the way.
I best he was here.
He's the great,
you guys had your show together.
Yeah.
Wait.
Yeah,
we just shutting up there.
Yeah.
I wrote it with him in mind.
This is before anything and I just was at like,
um,
when,
when you rode with him in mind and when you tell NBC like are they like,
I was very manipulative about it because I was like,
I'd never done anything before.
You know,
I was like a filthy like comic.
Like I was going to be like,
these are my demands that,
you know,
so I had to audition like 300 guys.
None of them were taller than me.
I mean,
it's all right.
How tall are you?
I'm five.
10.
I actually got shorter recently.
I went to the doctor and they're like,
you're five,
eight.
And I was like,
no,
I'm fine.
Like this business has just beat me.
I'm just losing like my,
just my spine.
Wait until you have a baby.
Your field grow and you'll get shorter.
How do we,
we've talked about this before and we were talking to you about showbusiness
before we ran the hit record here,
but we always felt like I'm serious.
Like Whitney Cummings really understands like how everything works.
She should have a seminar on fucking show you up.
Is it the ones getting millions of hits on your podcast and I'm writing scripts
and are getting picked humble and I'm like,
Oh shit,
we're talking about like early on it was,
I remember you being on roasts and I felt like you going from rose to television
I gave you,
I was like,
this is a calculated move on Whitney's part.
She knows to move the chess piece here and there.
And I was like,
I don't know how she knows she knows I the roasts.
Actually I was a writer on the roasts from remember that,
you know?
And they said,
no,
I tried to be a writer.
They were like,
no,
I just like sending them.
I like made them hire me and then they booked me for one roast.
It was Larry the cable guy and I was like so excited and then they said no.
Like,
it's just when people say,
think that I have had a good career,
like they just don't know about all the fat because for every one when you get
50 failures,
but no one promotes it,
no one,
there's no like,
you know,
news articles that are like,
so show not picked up.
Nobody can I tell you about.
So like,
I don't know when we were,
I don't know.
We're both kind of opened makers around same time.
I feel like
we were,
I know we were just hitting every laundromat bowling.
But here's the difference between Whitney Cummings and Christina P.
I remember one night in silver lake,
there was some dog shit dive bar and it was racist.
Maybe not,
not,
no,
no.
It was,
I don't even know if the place exists anymore.
And it was an open Mike,
Someone's house.
There's so much shit.
And uh,
and it was raining.
And so all that showed up were comedians because in La,
when it rains,
the audience doesn't come out right.
And I remember going up,
no one's here later,
I'm going to go get drunk and fuck around.
And she goes,
no,
Whitney coming.
She's,
you know,
we're all like fucking late twenties.
She goes,
all right,
well let's workshop guys,
come on,
let's just work,
shop our jokes.
And I was like,
God,
that's the difference between Whitney and me.
I'm like,
I'm going to go get hammered inlaid with Tommy.
Yeah,
like that.
It's hammered them hammered and then does that get fucked up?
I didn't get laid sober.
Don't worry.
I don't even remember who they were or now I got to get ripped before I fucked
this guy.
Um,
but that's a difference.
And I think like that's what we all were like,
damn.
Like she knows the matrix,
the matrix.
How did you know the Matrix already?
I went to flappers the other night cause that's where I go like try out new
stuff.
It's nice in Burbank and nobody showed up.
It's my shit.
And nobody showed up and were like four open microphone.
I was like,
can I just run these premises while you guys all right.
I think like I was just so afraid of being bad.
I was just so afraid of not being good.
And I think when you come up as a female,
you're already so hazed,
or at least at the time I had a lot of girls and it was like you have to,
I felt like you had to be twice as funny.
You know?
I was also so nervous on stage when I started,
like I didn't have that natural charisma.
Like I just,
you know how sometimes like there's comics who can on paper do jokes that
wouldn't necessarily make you laugh on paper,
but with their charisma and with how good of a performer they are.
Like I wasn't a good performer yet,
so I just felt like the jokes had to be so good that they had to,
you know,
override the fact that you were a hard worker.
But then also at Tommy saying like the business side of it,
you seem to know like,
oh my God,
if I do this,
I also thought because you had so much going on,
I was like,
one of the things that a lot of people struggle with,
and I think especially Comedians,
is having the audacity to say,
I want this,
this and this.
And in my mind you were,
you knew.
That's so interesting because I feel like I'm always like,
no,
you go,
I'm good.
Like I feel you know,
really.
So I that was like,
I mean when I was doing the roasts,
I mean,
you know,
it's weird that the fact that someone gets successful off the roast because it
works.
People,
they were,
especially back then in context,
like that time that was like the biggest thing happening in comedy where the
they like matter.
Yeah.
I mean even now,
like they'll go like four years without one and then all of a sudden they get
huge ratings because they can have it back.
The roasts work for comedy central,
it was like the Superbowl was like the Oscars for the comedy world kind of,
you know?
And which is tricky because it's hard.
I think that part of the reason that's a new person does so well because no
one's heard of him before,
you know,
and they just come out of nowhere and they can't really slam you on much because
you don't have,
all the jokes are like,
who the fuck are,
you know?
And then like sludge jokes,
which for women.
Yeah,
totally.
You're putting your Lisa Lampanelli,
he's pussy,
right?
Well it was like her,
that was a lot of Cox,
which by the way,
and then she's married to a white guy.
It's like you vote black guy.
She's like,
yeah,
you know,
it's like you just grab whatever you can and uh,
and then I did a special for them and I think that's the thing.
And they did warn me to give me an hour and I was like fought to get an hour
cause I didn't get this.
So that's what I'm talking about.
This so inside baseball,
but three months prior I didn't get live at Gotham.
Wow.
Which like,
it could be something like 150 comics.
Got It.
This is what I'm saying.
Never Know Montreal.
I know I like,
I never got the things that everyone got.
Like I just felt like I never could get in.
So I just,
the way the way,
but then how did you know,
how did you have the sense of like,
yeah,
I didn't get Gotham but I want an hour is when I'm asking.
Cause I had like worked my,
I had been getting nothing for so long that I had accumulated so much material.
I hadn't burned out.
I hadn't burned any of it,
you know,
like I had done the tonight show I think,
or something like when it was Leno,
when he like Conan got it.
And that like,
but I wasn't getting for like,
I wasn't getting anything,
so I just had so many chunks of 15 minutes,
you know,
and I was doing the road,
I was opening for Steve Byrne and Bobby Lee and Craig Shoemaker.
Wow.
I know.
So I just had a bunch of material,
but I just,
so I felt like I'd been struggling tooth and nail.
And by the time I did the NBC show,
I had written two pilots that hadn't gotten picked up.
Um,
I had written specs for pilots that didn't even exist.
Dane Cook had done a Spec or a,
I'm sorry,
a pilot at UPN and network that doesn't even exist anymore.
And I'd written a Spec like I was just always writing sort of pilots cause I was
like,
I don't think anyone's going to give this to me.
Like I just have to create my own opportunities and I was too weird to get cast
in anything.
I was always like too shrill or too tall or like I wasn't the like yeah
girlfriend.
Yeah.
Like I just was like,
I would always get feedback that was just like you're,
I remember an agent at ICM was like,
you're never going to be a leading lady.
Wow.
He was like,
well,
which is interesting cause he was like,
you're going to be like at best like Elisa Cuadro and I was like,
you mean the best accurate hero?
Like Ra are you trying to as part of,
are you trying to hurt my,
yeah,
they should.
They were just like,
you're too quirky.
Like you're too.
So I was just like,
I think I have to do this on my own because no one is going to enter Jada.
Pinkett like came out.
And you were like,
that's right.
I mean the Jadah I need that.
I need her I think is by the way,
it's so crazy.
I remember
being,
I was in [inaudible],
I was in Melbourne,
Australia with,
um,
Hannibal.
Yeah.
And we were talking,
I was like,
yeah.
Oh yeah.
My,
my half hour had come out,
like I always central half hour to come out,
uh,
four or five months prior.
Yeah.
And we were talking and I was like,
yeah,
so you're going to try to do the the half hour,
uh,
on this next round.
He was like,
I think we're just going to go for the hour.
And I was like,
why?
Yeah.
So crazy,
right?
You mean?
He's like,
yeah,
we're just going to go for the,
I'm like,
you can do that.
And he was like,
I mean,
I guess we're going to try.
I was like,
that's,
that to me,
blew my mind.
I was like,
you're going to skip that part.
Yeah.
Like you don't get to jump the line.
It was just like the kind of thing where it's like they had fucking,
three months later he shot it I way they had said no to me for so long.
I didn't get premium blend.
I didn't get live at Gotham.
I didn't get out that shit.
I never,
never got it.
And I was driving out to Irvine,
like,
you know,
putting in hair extensions in the car.
I mean I was the hustling and like nothing.
And I almost feel like at the time that was like my,
like what you guys do when you're like,
I'm just gonna take matters into my own hands and I'm just going to shoot
podcast and I'm going to go directly to my people like that.
I was like,
if you just give this to me,
I can find my people,
you know?
And I had a little bit of leverage I guess,
cause I had just done the roast and they wanted to kind of,
yeah,
when you have the leverage,
you've got a book.
Fucking really got to do it when you got you.
I know you gotta you gotta be with someone and you gotta be willing to say no.
Yeah.
Oh yeah,
you learn for me when we say no,
that's what years so cause he was like,
oh I just,
anyone that talks to me,
I just am like thank you.
Thank you that you know,
it was a big,
I don't know,
a reward for me to say no to is an audition that I'm like,
I don't want to fucking go out in that.
And I'm like,
what?
I used to be like,
I think I don't want to go out on it.
And they're like,
you should go.
And I was like,
all right,
I'll,
I'll be there.
And now I'm like,
I don't want to read for this bullshit.
And they're like,
okay,
you don't even want to go for the one day.
What if you get it?
You have to spend eight years doing it.
No,
no.
You know what I mean?
Those at all.
I didn't even want to go for 20 minutes.
You know what if I get this,
what if I get,
this was all it was.
The thing is,
I,
I'm always amazed by how many agents think the,
what if I get it is like why are we having that conversation?
I'm like,
that's the point of going no.
Then they go to me it will cause I'm like,
we can always say no,
but that's three days.
Why would I do that?
I have shit to do.
I always like,
where's this shoot?
And they're like,
I could find out,
find out,
always find out because I want to know if I'm moving.
And then they're like,
okay,
yeah,
yeah.
Does shooting from,
we don't think you're going to get it.
Cause like why,
why would I go,
you're just doing this to seem like you're doing your job.
But you know,
I don't even have,
I don't even go out on them ever.
I don't even have an agent for theatrical smell so bad.
Everything's sucks so bad.
It hurt your feelings every time.
They're like,
hey,
the money for this,
you know,
you get the script and it's like grandmother,
Alcoholic Gray,
like you're just hurting my feelings.
40 she's like fucking everyone at the funeral.
Like that's what I get.
And they're like,
they love you for this.
And I'm like,
I don't even,
I don't get is the right direction.
I want to write our own shit.
That's why I went to cvs.
It's like I'd rather write the vehicle for us.
I waited for that,
for,
for that.
Yes.
That's not to fucking,
they're not going to,
I'm not the neighbor.
I'm not the fucking the fuck machine girl anyway.
I don't even try out what's the point?
And um,
you know,
and it's also thinking about like,
who are the great comics?
They were like,
oh yeah,
they got cast in that thing.
Like this Gal Finacle like that's a great example.
Like he was already doing standup,
but it was something that he made his own.
Anyway,
Todd Phillips was like,
do your thing,
but it's very,
you're not like Jerry Seinfeld got cast in that incredible show and then he did
his own show.
Like that's never been anyone's trajectory.
Like Mary Rice Gob did that.
She's amazing.
Like she did that 24 show and was like,
great,
but made it her own special thing.
But I don't think anyone sort of popped off of doing someone else's thing.
She was constantly marrying,
making it up instantly.
No,
you're right.
You have to make it your own.
I think it's like,
dude,
did you see their special is amazing.
Oh,
and they're on that show sometimes Patton Oswald,
he was like on other shows,
but no one's like,
yeah,
I love him on that show.
You'll ease standups.
Amazing.
I'm not too long ago where the description was very detailed for a nerdy
computer guy.
I'm like,
God,
Amen.
Don't you think?
Let me,
I realized acting is not playing yourself,
but do you think they'll get like the nerdy computer looking guy?
Yeah,
they'll call Kevin Christie.
you should just,
you should go in.
And I was like,
no,
cause I,
I know they're going to,
but a lot of it is like casting director,
like having been on both sides.
A lot of his casting director is like fan.
They like you,
they just want to see you like,
and then it's like,
well no,
they'll cast you in something else.
It's like,
I don't have time to go on weird dates.
I got a lot going on in Van Nuys.
Oh.
And also if I see in the character description sexy,
I'm like,
like,
have you seen anything?
Like,
I like,
like,
I like it when they try to make it so she's not pretty in the description.
It's like not a threat,
you know?
It's always something that's like,
not going to steal your man,
but like,
yeah,
I love that.
Also,
it's super insulting when it's like,
it's like,
you know,
Lindsay,
25 smart.
It's like you think I assumed a woman wouldn't be smart,
so you will have to qualify.
Yeah,
smart.
Down to Earth.
It's like,
you know,
some women just are that.
Well,
that's the other thing too,
is that they really don't.
Right.
Am I still,
they still write us very well,
so I'm like,
I'd rather write my own thing and do that.
Then wait for it.
Make sure you're with someone that is interested in mastering themselves and
everything that they come with.
And I know that there's a lot of pain that comes with infidelity,
but relationships is a spiritual endeavor.
Just make sure you with somebody who's worth,
so we got engaged recently and that's why we wanted to bring Jada pink into the
mix here.
Keith or can I just really quick,
sorry.
I'm always to have the wrong takeaway.
I'm always the one when you just show me a photo.
I'm like,
what's that thing in the background?
Like I watched two different earrings so she had so much money that she's just
like,
I got to,
I know I can't decide which jewels to where is so pretty.
Why does she look?
She's Benjamin Button and why does she look 20 now?
It's like find someone that can,
like if I looked like you,
I wouldn't have to take your money and you should see her mom gammy on red table
talk.
Gammy looks better than I of us,
which has a six pack.
Her mom has a six pack.
Do you do with skincare video?
I don't care.
I don't need your relationship and flights
she hates will bring up.
Yeah.
Why don't you bring up infidelity lot.
It felt like,
okay.
That just felt like a weird,
like no one was thinking about that.
A lot of resentment I did.
What am I in for?
It's awesome.
Yeah,
we've been married.
Our 10 year anniversary is coming up November and ears.
That's crazy.
Together or like,
yeah,
like a bunch of years.
I feel like before,
I remember seeing you guys at like Jerry's Deli in the valley,
but remember there was that,
that comedy on a box.
You did comedy on like a China mob,
like you would look down at the people eating.
They're like Salami or whatever and I remember you guys and I'm like,
oh,
they're to get like comics dating.
I was like,
that's never going to work.
Calmly stated comments.
Good luck with that and here you are.
You get,
wait,
sorry.
Did you Mary,
are you marrying a comedian or a lay person?
He's not a comic as a lay person.
He's a pedestrian.
I don't.
I had no idea it was going to happen.
I was,
we had met on the Internet long distance.
We met on a dating app,
totally
behind him.
It's like you have to like get accepted.
It's like what?
It's all like Hollywood.
It's all like the dudes in Hollywood I've been trying to avoid for the past 15
years.
It's like pivot and Matthew pair.
It's like,
Oh God,
these are all the people I've been trying to avoid hearing Matthew Perry's name
a lot on it.
What's it like?
What is the guy who hits up Whitney Cummings now?
You know what's funny is when I was on Tinder for a while to smash and I,
and I,
uh,
because I was like,
what's the difference when meeting someone at a bar?
Like it's,
it might be safe or I can get to know them.
And then one time I had this guy meet me at the comedy store and just to be
like,
okay,
this could be dangerous to meet me in the comedy.
So like what could happen?
And he was gonna come see a show or whatever.
And then I saw him and we were texting for like three,
four weeks.
He sees me and I'm like,
hey.
And he was like,
I didn't think it was really going to be you.
And I was like,
what?
Like first of all,
who,
if someone was going to impersonate someone that,
why would they pick me?
Like I'm not as a standup comic,
but also like was he like wanted to be catfished I think.
I think it was like,
I was like,
no,
I'm like,
so you prefer to have the person pretending?
Like he was just like,
can I get a picture?
Like it was very weird.
And then he just like left.
I thought we were like going on a date.
So I was like,
I think this is probably sketchy.
So then I went on this other one,
which is kind of people that are sort of in our field in some way.
Like my guy works advice,
he's not in our business.
Um,
but we started texting is not Shane Black?
No,
I would not be here.
I would be in France on a boat somewhere.
Um,
but uh,
he is super cool.
He like had sort of knew about me but wasn't,
he's like,
I've seen you on talk shows.
He's like,
I don't really know because when people say like,
I've never heard of you,
and you're like,
I have to say like,
go out of your way to be arrogant.
But it's just sort of like,
you definitely went to my Instagram from this.
Like,
you know what I do?
Have you ever met a comedian who's like a big comedian?
And they're like,
oh,
hi.
Um,
uh,
what's up?
You Google me every day and you're like,
hey man,
what are you,
uh,
are you a comic?
And you're like,
you come on.
And then they're like,
uh,
are you,
opening for someone here?
And you're like,
no,
I'm not.
And then you're like,
okay,
we're on the same poster.
Like,
come on man.
I love that.
I also love the backhanded compliments you get offstage.
Oh God.
We talk about this with the lean maniac about this by the way.
I get so fired up about,
about the,
uh,
the people that give the backhanded today.
That's my favorite shit.
Oh yeah.
We've talked about it constantly is the craziest cause he's just,
the building is shaped but it's like I'll get off stage and someone's like weird
crowd and you're like,
what?
Like don't do it.
It's like such a subtle,
yeah,
like you're too smart for them.
They tried to give you a compliment as a way to insult you just went over their
heads but I thought I did.
I just did great.
Yeah I forgot about that one or that will,
maybe it's this one when you come off stage and you kill and they're like great
crowd and you're like,
no,
the crowd didn't do that work.
Right.
Like that's not great crowd.
You know,
diminishing or,
or when someone is not a comic,
that kind of Shit.
They were like,
I remember one time someone came up to me after a show and they're like,
I could never do that.
I'm like,
what?
Like it's just like a weird little like it doesn't seem,
yeah,
I know you're saying it doesn't seem 100% pod.
I don't know how you do it.
It'd be like you wouldn't understand.
You want to find my best friend likes you.
That's always weird.
Have my friend likes you or not the girlfriend clearly doesn't guys want to do
that?
Guys always want to come up to me and be like,
Hey,
I don't know who you are,
but we just take a picture of me for my girlfriend.
I'm like,
all right.
I get the opposite.
I get,
I get the guy.
My favorite is when the guy goes,
dude,
picture and I'm like,
okay,
and then he's like,
babe and she's like,
I'm good.
All
guys at the airport.
I'm like,
come on man.
That's so funny.
I get a lot of you guys probably get this because you have a,
like,
you're so known by your fans.
Like I get a lot of people who are like,
Hey,
my phone's charging.
Could you just take a picture and email it to me?
Oh my God.
I'm like,
what is the five I'm giving off?
And then they're like,
how's your knee?
I'm like,
what?
How do you know?
Born in a podcast?
People just think you're friends for sure.
Absolutely.
I kind of enjoy that though because I feel like they know what they're getting
when they come to a show.
Then the whole thing of them being like,
what a lady saying crazy shit like yes bro.
Like you're on board told or that you like the real downside though,
being engaged is it takes so many opportunities off the table seeing that a lot
of women,
can you making these videos of why they like the bad boys there?
You just don't sell yourself short.
It's yourself a man.
So actually professor the bad boy that'll possibly just steal your heart
toy with it.
Hey,
you're looking at the good time.
That's more just be goofy.
Whichever
that's sconce is not my favorite.
Are you into like posters?
That's not what that is.
I the MAC is that a row?
It's comfortable just being himself.
There you that's true.
It's not,
it's wait,
you already say stop looking so hard.
Stop looking at what is that?
Is that a famous person?
No,
there's all these like Weirdos on Instagram that I feel like I've gotten famous
and I'm never not working so hard or easy to find.
Ah,
those sunglasses.
Farmer's Tan.
Yes.
He ever from goggles or something.
I mean,
you're just going to leave that out there.
I don't know what to do.
See,
this is why I want to get engaged again.
Yeah.
Like I want to get married tomorrow.
Videos like that,
bad boys out there that are so hard to resist.
Think my base if that,
or we do.
We say that,
I don't even know.
People are starting to your base and your brand.
I'm like,
I don't know what that means,
but like I don't think that the guys that my success has been from guys that
think I'm going to date them after.
I don't think,
no,
I wouldn't say that's what you're putting out there.
Oh No.
Looks,
people are like,
are you worried that now you're engaged,
you're going to lose fans?
I'm like,
I don't like people were like tolerating my comedy because they thought at the
end we were going to date.
Like that's the,
I get like girls.
Yeah,
that's what you,
I think like a garage,
you guys that really have that,
um,
worry before.
I've talked to guys who are like,
oh no,
I know.
I know tons of comics who like are in relationships,
but don't put it on their Instagram and stuff like that.
But I,
uh,
I,
I think guys,
I'm like,
I still think it's weird.
It's like they're not the,
are they really going to your shows cause you're available?
I don't think so.
You know,
I think that,
I think that actually,
this is obviously why did it,
but I think it helps because sometimes I do make fun of guys and girls.
It's like I don't hate men.
I'm not a man hater.
I love men.
I'm marrying one.
I'm going to share a toilet with Wa.
Like I love men.
I Make Fun of the idiots like that fucking guy.
But I think it's,
it's good to remind people like,
I'm not this bitter spinster who's like,
oh,
of course man,
you really want to make you squirm.
So we brought out,
I'm one of our,
yeah,
this,
get uncomfortable.
Get uncomfortable.
Imagine,
imagine you're not engaged,
right?
Let's go back maybe a couple of years.
I,
you're single.
He's like a month.
Let me,
let's say you're single,
you're single,
you're single and you're out and you have a night out and you know you're,
you're approachable.
You're personable person.
Yeah.
Somebody comes up to you and they're like,
oh hey crowd.
Yeah.
I mean I would've laughed anyway.
Then you have a little chat with them and you're like,
oh blah,
blah blah.
And then for whatever reason,
maybe you a couple of drinks,
you exchange information but you don't think much of it.
Okay.
And the next morning,
the next morning you wake up to this.
Good morning,
Julia,
just me Gel.
Just wanted to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
Tell you that me and you.
Yes.
Did I am getting a look at you was probably one of the greatest moments in my
life.
Get out of here
you are to me.
I mean just,
you're gorgeous.
You're that fan off.
So sitting in my mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with your ex boyfriend,
please erase them from your memory.
Don't ever go back in the past.
I know because I've been there.
Have you and I understand when you know you're trying to find somebody and go on
dates and not the compares to your racks,
but there is that.
How many fans do you have?
Got a lot of failures.
Really Complain Shoe.
It is me,
me and you.
We have great ventilation in here.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
he brags about it.
He brags because he actually built this whole house every time.
All the gods.
Your opener,
right?
Coming at you from the House I built.
That's why.
That's,
that's where you start marketing
and then I'm in.
I'm like this mother fucking build a house.
Yes.
My ex is looking pretty wide right now.
Yeah,
right.
That's lead with your strengths.
What is this facial?
Never been loved before.
Oh,
did we?
Just me.
I'll make you feel like a woman.
It may feel like what?
What does that even mean?
After you experienced me?
You won't even know who your ex boyfriend is.
Wow.
So you're going to give me a lobotomy with your Dick.
I will.
Yeah.
Julia,
it's sad tense.
Let's go get to the whole other level here.
Open up your heart to me in your arms.
Let's go full throttle.
Gotcha.
Is this about fucking her love?
He's just,
he's obsessive boundaries.
Just a random guy.
This has got to be to me.
I mean what I feel when I watch it,
I love ritual by the way.
It's not going to get me in trouble.
No,
no,
not at all.
There's,
there's the,
the level of embarrassment I feel for him because everyone has,
has done something to a degree.
Yeah,
of course.
You know where you send a text,
but the fact that he went full throttle,
no,
it's full throttle.
Full travel.
But who,
who did he say he sent you said this to eight 19 year old freshman in college
and he's obviously not.
And uh,
and she blasted it.
She said it to her friends and then it grew from there.
Yeah.
Julia,
let's go full throttle.
Yeah.
How have you met guys like that went anywhere?
They know what they're obsessed had that no.
I look at the sky and I'm like,
if I had that kind of confidence and I would have everything I want in life.
Do you do that?
You have that kind of confidence?
That's what I'm trying to tell you.
You go full throttle all the time.
Go full throttle.
And then my next special,
if you're going to shoot one,
two,
are you excited?
Yes,
a little bit.
I'm a little bit like even touring,
right?
Yeah.
I've been touring like I've been doing clubs just to run it over and theaters
you.
I feel like there's this thing with comics now.
Like where if you're not doing theaters,
like people think you're,
you can't do them and you're like,
well I don't want to do clubs cause everyone's gonna think I can't do theater
and to get the reps it's so,
yeah,
it's just like with social media now it's like everyone's like,
I find myself doing it like comparing and all this kind of stuff and I'm like,
I'm just going to do my thing.
I'm going to do clubs.
Cause that's the only way I know how to get ready for a special
cause you can do,
I'm like,
I want to change this and I can do it in an hour.
Where are you shooting?
DC?
Yeah.
OK.
I was just so the other day checking out theaters and um,
I uh,
I'm doing it.
I just,
there's a little bit in my head now and I think this is new for comics where
it's like,
am I going to get fucking shit that someone going to think that's racist?
People are gonna think that's sexist.
And I find myself like totally over.
I gotta get Outta there.
I know I'm scared.
I just did a half hour.
The degenerates.
Yeah.
Cause I want to add topical material and the me too thing and I didn't want to
wait to put it on an hour and a year from now and I'm like,
God,
thank God I'm kind of protected by the degenerates.
Yeah,
that's right.
This is going to protect you just this much.
That's what it's called.
Shit you're going to say.
I agree with where I say like,
you're slutty Indian costume is kind of that.
I'm just like,
do I have to say native Americans?
Oh my God,
do I have to change that?
It's just we're in this fucking walking on eggshells and it's like comps shit
that you don't respond at all.
Never engage.
See,
that's so smart.
Because I was like,
I have such a hard time,
not not getting the last word or just being standing up for yourself,
you know,
when you're getting attack.
But if you feel like something's really misrepresented,
yeah.
You're just like disengage the most.
Well,
because comics,
I think that the thing that sort of our engine is like,
we want to get to the truth.
Like we're obsessed with justice,
right?
So it's like the idea of someone saying somebody that's not true.
It's like I have such a hard time not being,
but handle it the way you imagine a really,
really,
really famous person would handle it.
They would not entertain,
have their wife.
Uh,
I'm gonna have Jadah hand.
No,
I'm not dealing with this.
But I just,
it's tricky cause comics,
like we thrive on feedback.
That's how we get better.
But then it's like that feedback I just have to ignore and it's just like kind
of a mind fuck.
So,
um,
so yeah.
And I have some of the me too stuff too,
but I'm like,
Ugh,
this is going to be too late,
like in this kind of a hard,
well I wanted to make fun of the particular people at the,
at the moment.
Even now I look at those jokes,
I got a few Louie jokes and I was like,
oh fuck.
Like he had gone out into the clubs and I wish I had been able to write about
what he's recently from Bull Shit.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what you get to do this do to your jokes on your podcast or like the
things your thoughts,
you know,
cause there's so much to chime in on.
You can just do it now.
I know.
It's frustrating.
I kinda,
yeah,
well anyway,
um,
so that's exciting.
So when do you shoot the,
so I'm shooting it in like three months.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Cause it's also,
it's like it's the last three specials I did were con hours used to be 45
minutes.
Yes.
With commercials.
Now there's 60 minutes,
you know,
so,
but I do think that the,
the best formula for,
for doing them yeah.
Is as close to on the shorter side of 60.
Yup.
As,
as you can be good.
You really feel like good point.
A lot of them have fucked up with being and I fucked up.
I mean,
because you get kind of like,
well I'll just leave it all in,
you know,
and it's like 72
yeah.
And you're like,
uh,
no.
Just save it for the tour and they get to do it on the next one,
make it 58 for smart.
That's really smart.
I think those are the best ones.
And all of our attention spans now are just be weightless.
Your grammar.
It's like a minute.
Oh,
do the reason they're even our 30 and 15 minutes specials now.
Yeah.
Because the data shows them,
yeah.
The bed arts.
Yes.
So I mean that's,
that's a people or stuff that I love.
I'm probably watching someone's,
our are on Netflix and I just don't have the time cause I got a kid screaming or
I'm like,
yeah,
fuck I want to whine.
I can't.
Yeah,
I'll get to it.
Yeah.
So it's like,
I'm just trying to figure out how to,
it's just like you guys keep saying like,
I know how to do business.
It's like this business keeps changing every minute.
Like my last special I did HBO,
I probably should have done that.
Blacks,
you know,
but it was like Hbo,
like that's your dream as a comment.
And then I'm like now to get on Hbo you have to put in nine passwords.
Like you have to like,
you know,
it's like hieroglyphics.
Like it's just like a whole thing.
Like no one can even find it,
you know?
Yeah.
Be,
it was the mountain top.
I mean,
when we were growing up.
Yeah.
So it was like my dream to always have an HBO special and then Netflix was just
happening and I was like,
oh,
Netflix,
what's that?
Like the streaming thing,
like that males,
you DVD.
I'm like,
you idiot.
Judged or not feel like I'm always like behind on that
guy.
By the way,
the Good Morning Julia Guy,
it was such a hit with our audience.
May think that they have been recording themselves to God.
This is my favorite part of our show.
You want to know who your ex boyfriend is?
All right,
so here is some,
this is Andre who made his own.
Good Morning Julia.
Perfect frame.
It's me,
Joe Posters.
Just want to say hi.
Wish you a great day.
I'll tell you that a mean you yesterday and getting a look at you [inaudible]
circle today.
Moments in my life.
You were so beautiful.
You don't know how beautiful you are to me.
I'm here to me.
Everyone else doesn't jus and uh,
it's been sitting in my mind when you said to me,
you want to go back with your ex boyfriend threes erase them from your memory.
You'll never go back in the past.
I know because I've been there just to get them saying you're trying to find
somebody.
Can you go on dates?
Nothing compares to your ex,
but there is a [inaudible] and Julia,
I promise you it is me.
I will love you.
Oh my God.
His voice never been loved before.
I will chair a shoe.
I'll make them feel like a woman.
A real woman.
Why is that?
So as you're reading from me,
maybe that's your experienced me.
You won't ever know who your ex boyfriend is.
Still open up your heart to me in your arm to me.
Let's go full throttle.
Full throttle.
What does that mean?
I'm,
if I'm trying to think.
If you were having sex.
Yeah.
And he said to you,
dead
serious.
I want to,
uh,
does that make you feel like a woman?
What would you do?
Well that's the thing.
It's just what does that,
even though it's an antiquated POV,
it's a guy who's going like,
uh,
you know,
I'll make a lady feel like a lady cause he's,
he's fucking,
it's like a chivalry.
Oh.
Oh,
I'm going to hold it.
I thought it was sexual.
Like you're going to know I'm going to hold the going,
lay my coat down on a puddle of water.
So you don't come in to laid down my leather bomber jacket from the 80s I like
that though.
I like chivalry.
That's why that timing.
But I feel like a woman.
Is it like I feel like I have cramps.
I,
that's what I feel like a woman every day.
I don't want to feel anymore like a woman.
That quick sample of what Scott did here,
the baby teeth
say getting to meet you and spend time with you yesterday was one of the best
days of my life.
I could really see myself falling in love with you with the,
with those pretty eyes,
your gorgeous.
And I built everything here in this house myself,
the cabinets in the crown molding trim on the cabinets.
And I just want to say,
ah,
you know,
you're beautiful and you should,
you should never go back with that other baby.
And uh,
I hope this video doesn't scare you.
So I love you baby doll.
What does that town no more?
Oh my God.
What would you do?
Why wouldn't you just send a text saying like,
Hey,
love to see you again.
Probably.
He probably left there.
I kind of identify to a degree where like I remember,
you know that dude probably hasn't at his age,
hasn't taught,
probably even spoken to a young,
a young girl.
She loves videos.
She's young and he,
he,
she probably gave him a tension,
you know,
like in that conversation he was like this is it.
This is the girl he went into like a fantasy land of this is how I'm gonna
marry.
You know,
this is my lady right here.
Did you do that with her?
Absolutely.
Now and then
and then he went into,
he went into,
he laid out,
he saw the like he,
I'm going to send her this video,
she's going to respond and like it's going to go off.
Cause he probably remembered moments when they were having a drink or sharing an
Uber or whatever the fuck they were doing that he was like this is special.
He started to tell himself that it was more significant.
Right.
That's what it wants to,
yeah,
you're right.
You're just waiting for teenage girls do teenagers.
He fills your old girls to be clear.
He feels this way for every girl that gives him attention.
That's the problem.
There's a meal on it in any way,
Julius.
I think the thing I did it because our friend of someone who wrote in to the
show knows the girl that he sent it to her to get her on.
We got to get them on.
She was a university of fucking Iowa fresh,
you're going to say University of Phoenix.
Uh,
university of items,
real play.
And she,
um,
you know,
just probably was,
had a couple drinks and was just talking to a guy and he just took it to,
this is my soul mate,
you know?
No,
it was heartbreaking.
I woke up so excited.
Ah,
I don't know if you noticed about,
I changed the locks on your door.
Now I can come in and fix you up your water heater.
I can fix his septic.
I can wait.
I'll put him beautiful marble.
Love you like no one's shit,
man.
Me.
You know what I'm saying?
Let's go for travel fucking thing.
You May,
cy made a curse,
but fuck,
I wanna fuck you.
Pretty bad.
I had a guy,
when I first talked to Chris,
this was an older guy who sat me down and pitched himself to me and he's like,
I can make pasta.
This is what I want to do.
Like it was like giving me like his skills.
Like it was literally like,
I have a car,
I have my own house.
They know.
It was just sort of this thing of like I date like drug addict,
homeless drug addict.
Like none of this is,
you know,
like it was the point in my life where I was dating monsters,
you know?
Yeah.
It was just sort of this like,
oh,
like I guess if you're a guy you just have to pitch your skill.
Well I think every,
I think every guy knows what's going on with that guy because you see,
you know the element of your brain that might lead you to do something like
that.
But 95% of us would raise,
like you might have a thought.
I met that girl.
I want to send her a bit like,
and you're like,
what are you out of your fucking mind?
No.
So yeah.
Then you send a text or you know,
you play out.
What's the way to approach this?
That guy just doesn't have,
he doesn't have the ability to stop a bad,
I can't exactly an aspergers thing where they don't read the room and he's just
going to do what he wants to do and worked with a guy one time who he was really
nice and I could tell something was off like something was definitely off.
And he brought up Jessica Biel one time and he was like,
I love her.
Like I love her so much.
And I was like,
okay.
And he's like,
yeah,
I got like,
I got pictures over all over my room and I was,
why?
He's
like,
I'm going to be with her.
He was probably like late twenties.
Um,
there was a moment where people were using the secret is a way to justify being
stockers.
Maybe you're right.
Like I have photos of this person ever because I'm trying to manifest them.
This guy was a real,
yeah,
this guy was a real gentle,
if she dies and you're going to jail,
he should find it.
Your Vision Board game and stocker board,
female celebrities on your wall,
late twenties guy.
And he was like,
you know,
he would go to the,
I remember he was like,
I go to the beach,
I serve and like I just think about Jessica Biel all day.
I was like,
no,
no go.
You really think you're going to end up with her.
He was like,
I really do.
And then I would obviously like ask about it all the time.
I was like,
how's Jessica?
He's like,
yeah,
you know I,
I put up some new pictures of her this weekend and I was like,
no,
no.
Yeah.
He was really,
really obsessed with,
which is so funny cause these days you'd have to print them.
I mean it's like,
it's not that you don't even tear them out of magazines.
Like we could at least tear them out of until now.
You have to like print paramount.
Yeah,
it's super creepy really.
And here's the thing we were working in,
we were working as site reps for productions.
So we would go to a,
he's waiting to be on a movie with her probably.
I mean like we would have huge,
I mean I did,
I did one of the site reps jobs with Beyonce.
So I mean any,
you know,
she could have been at any of these things.
And yeah,
he was really,
you just really made me realize something in myself that I'm deeply ashamed of,
which is I think that like,
cause when you're these thoughts,
whatever you're about to say,
I love,
well I have the worst one at the proposal that I feel like all know you guys
aren't going to understand that.
I feel like I have to ask you about.
But like when I,
there is this part of your brain,
I think for me,
where I always think I'm in the running.
Like when I saw,
I don't know anything about the royal family,
I don't really follow that stuff.
But I saw that Meghan Markle wasn't,
I didn't really know who she,
I didn't really know who he like and I was like,
fucking bitch.
I thought in my head I was like,
she took and I'm like,
I wasn't in the running for that.
Oh
man,
there's this little thing in your head that's just the craziest shit waiting.
I'm all,
wait a minute.
Oh,
I've never done that.
I was on board and I was like,
yeah,
but it's like,
you know how you're just kinda like,
whenever a male celebrity gets married,
a little part of me is like that,
but that could have been me.
I wasn't in the running leg was Disney movies.
Like something got in my head that that was your man that made me like compete.
Who was your man?
Wait,
who did you,
who are you bummed out that got married?
Prince.
Is it
the new one?
I ginger walk.
I saw all these photos of them when I first saw it and they were like,
they're engaged.
And I was like,
ah,
fuck it.
I know.
Like she took that horrible Gig to be,
I would never want to have right Johnny hose all day.
You're not allowed to wear eat Sushi chefs in nightmare you can't eat is that
you can't eat Sushi.
You can't have dark nail Polish,
which of course were wearing the exact,
I know like,
wait,
why can't you eat Sushi?
Because something about mercury or like point like fish poisoning because their
people are probably always trying to poison them or something.
I Dunno.
Interest.
I saw some article that was like,
what Meghan Markle can't do anymore.
Really?
What else?
Tell me the panty hose.
She's not allowed to wear dark nail Polish.
She's not allowed to eat fish or maybe it's just the queen doesn't like
something.
She's not let Deborah and cell phone.
She's not let him social media.
I was like,
I can never do this.
She can have her own phone.
I don't think so.
Well that's like a security I guess,
which that kind of makes sense.
They had to,
I don't understand it
because so many people came out of there.
She was abroad somewhere in Asia and people just came out of their homes and
businesses and swarmed this area.
So they had to like what a nightmare.
That's a nightmare that happened at my dad's funeral.
I mean,
not like that.
I'm not,
I was at my dad's funeral and I guess some people had known my dad was going to
die,
like a couple people showed up to take pictures and I did it of course.
But it was just,
I wasn't like,
it was actually kind of Nice cause it was a little bit of a distraction.
That was like,
great,
let's like take off your dad's funeral national filter.
Um,
yeah.
Like it's just like,
it was like on Facebook or something and you're like,
people like,
what are you dangling?
So that's gross.
And it's like I'm not like a,
yeah,
like a year and a half ago.
But when,
oh,
but when he proposed,
what was your first thought?
Uh,
okay.
So he,
yeah,
he,
he goes,
come over here and I go,
I don't want to smell your fart.
That was my first thought because he always used to fart and then pull me into
the park.
You still do.
So I thought you were tricking me.
Fart cloud.
I thought he was tricking me.
So when he first did it,
the way he was clear,
he tricked me.
No,
I like,
you know,
you go like,
oh my God,
are you serious?
Like do you mean it?
Like you're like,
oh wow,
that's great.
Wait,
wait.
But he just did it like where was it in our apartment and our apartment at a
just out of nowhere I,
but we're coming back from Irvine.
We had done a show.
And what made you choose?
So I bought like,
I know he gets dragged through the ringer on this.
Oh that I'm all about the ring.
I was going to do it,
let's say in September.
Yeah,
I was gonna do it.
New Year's we're going to do with this vacation.
The keys.
I was like,
that's perfect.
I know it was burning a hole in my pocket.
I was thinking about it all the time.
So I,
my dude was like,
having getting proposing is actually cool because you feel like an action hero
all the time because you're always like trying to hide a diamond.
You're like a jewel.
That's funny.
He,
and when I asked him,
I was like,
well where did you have at the whole time it's like totally like ruin the
moment.
Cause he was like,
oh,
I just kept it in the washing machine because I knew you'd never look there.
It's like,
that's really fun.
So he just hit it like we're cleaning supplies are hilarious.
So you just,
you just had it on your person?
I would like,
I would look for it all the time and like
dress and I took it to like the show because I was like,
I didn't want to leave it and then you have just let it fly with it because
we've had to fly to the keys with it.
And I was always,
I was like,
there's no way I'll be able to hold on another six,
eight weeks to do this.
No.
Is it where I was like,
I just,
you know,
I'm going to do it right now.
I didn't,
that wasn't a plan.
It was obviously like just,
you know,
I did pretty well tonight.
I feel like it was October 8th we got engaged.
It was November,
November 7th,
seventh we got married November.
Right.
Sorry.
Yeah,
it's been a,
wow,
look what he's got.
Wonderful,
beautiful,
radiant teeth.
Let's talk about that.
Hold on.
We always are fascinated by teeth and,
oh my God,
I have big t perfect,
gorgeous.
Let's about all kinds of braces and everything.
I had clear braces.
I begged my uncle or whoever was paying for my braces.
So ask me how my childhood and a whatever,
like stranger that was donating to the Kickstarter,
that was my teeth as a kid,
I want to clear braces because I did remember the clearer it must've been.
Wait,
no,
when we were kids it was way more expensive.
They were way more expensive and they didn't work.
Oh yeah.
They were way more intense and they're actually,
cause they,
they were,
you had to adjust them too much was I don't remember what it was,
but they were less,
oh they said you have to wear them twice as long.
And I was like,
fine.
You know,
I just like,
because my last name was Cummings and I already got bullied and I,
yeah,
I was just like,
I can't add any more jokes to my face.
So I was already cum,
shot and cum in your mouth.
I'm like at seven,
you know,
before I even knew what it was like.
And uh,
so I was like,
I need to clear races.
It takes twice as long and they turn whatever color food you're eating.
So there's no such thing as clear braces,
yell,
they're disgusting.
They just collect food from what I remember,
rose.
So they didn't really take,
and I pulled them off.
I remember one night cause I was like so embarrassed.
And then now I do the Invisalign thing.
Oh,
so you don't do it now I have it.
Yeah.
I'm not wearing it right now,
but I do it like a radically,
I always lose teeth.
They're really sensitive teeth,
like zoom and stuff.
I do.
No,
I don't do the whitening,
but I can't drink cold water.
I can't have ice so I have to use like some special toothpaste.
It's really Sensodyne barrow to saying yes,
they're a sponsor.
Yes.
If not,
do you do you wait a minute though.
I bet you you do a lot of
care though,
right?
You know what?
I try.
You got to come across as having impeccable dental hygiene.
Yes,
we,
it's been legal.
It I'm slipping.
I started getting this because I used to take Lunesta and all that shit and now
I just do like the vape before I go to bed and I wake up like fully clothed and
I'm like,
God damn man.
So it's like all my night hygiene has been kind of slipping,
but I try to do the little flosser things.
Refresh it.
You do whitening strips like the crest ones or do you do with dental whitening
professional?
I haven't done whitening.
Your teeth are very right.
I do it.
I have white professional whitening.
I go every few years.
I have a freshman,
Freshman,
oh shit.
I know you done the granny yellow.
They're getting a little Janky.
Very lucky.
Thank you.
The,
and they do what they do is they,
uh,
when Invisalign,
they have to file them to get more space in between them.
So when you don't use Invisalign,
then you just have like weird holes.
So I'm just like,
I need to be better about the Invisalign.
I just lose it.
Like we travel so much.
I lose my tray.
Oh my God.
I know what I wanted to ask you.
I follow you on Instagram and I've noticed that you're very,
uh,
into your skincare regimen regime.
Is that the word regimen or regime?
This regime regime is like you,
you're a leader for regime.
But I might have a skincare regime at some point if comedy doesn't work out.
No,
but you're very disciplined and you do what you're supposed to do.
Have you read my comments?
Now?
I'm in a constant state of fear of aging,
so I'm just constantly just putting shit.
Oh,
is that,
yeah.
I don't have television came in and really fucked things up.
I mean,
I'd have television picks up more than the human eye picks up.
I remember one time I was shooting a show,
we had an actress,
the most beautiful,
gorgeous,
stunning Irish,
um,
really pale skin.
Just stunning.
Gets in hair and makeup,
goes on camera.
All of a sudden her face is covered and freckles.
Oh,
the camera.
Yeah.
It was just like the human eye can't pick it up and she just had little freckles
everywhere and it was,
you know,
and like,
I don't think she even knew it.
It's a magnifying glass.
So we had to fix it in post production,
so she never saw it.
She reminds me to,
uh,
she's like,
do you ever wash your face?
And I'm like,
oh,
she's never,
I have this whole thing with my guy right now.
We'll,
beards are a whole thing too.
Yes.
Smells that he got.
It's like they get the,
they to smell.
It's always like chowder.
It's so gross.
Yeah.
They get the follicles get all clogged and you have to get in there and wash
them.
But he got a little thing that like cleans it.
It's like a prescription.
Yeah.
But you got to wash your face and on the road is just like tricky cause you're
with all the shitty water in different cities.
So do you,
do you take your whole skin care thing?
Like on the,
cause I know you have a go,
you do the roller.
I just do it on Instagram.
I feel like when people,
when you do something on Instagram,
people will assume you do it constantly.
Like oh I thought you could pretty much only do it when I'm filming,
you know?
Okay.
Cause I'm like damn,
she's so disciplined.
Like no,
I don't do it every night.
But I tried to do that look cause I don't like look,
look at all the famous female comics,
have any,
not gotten crazy work and they kind of have to at some point I'm worried.
Even Richard,
Jenny was starting to do like I'm concerned about,
what's his name?
Uh,
Yup.
I know who you're thinking.
I know we're talking about yes.
Has It 16 year old
girlfriend?
No,
no,
I was thinking of a Vegas.
No,
I was thinking of actually who passed away.
Um,
oh,
you weren't even thinking of it.
And I was thinking of Guy,
uh,
Shandling.
Yeah.
Ooh,
yeah.
So it's like what,
what did,
I don't know what that is.
Maybe the same thing that makes us comics and want to go make strangers laugh is
the same thing that makes us dysmorphic or
uh,
aging and,
and like people,
I could,
people all the time hit me up in there like,
but you can have a beard.
We can't,
but I get there like,
um,
you know,
you look,
you look
like someone's creepy uncle.
You Shave your head,
your,
you know,
your head,
the ball.
I say something about that that's maybe helpful.
Not,
I think with comics people try to be funny and it's,
it's like,
it's not an insult.
They would say if you weren't a comic,
they're just kind of trying to like forge a bond with you.
Like I,
people come up to me in airports all the time and they say,
should,
that's so me.
And I think it's just like,
oh,
you were on the roast,
like Rosewood a clot in your lungs,
right?
People call you kind of more all the time,
all the time.
You know what I mean?
So I'm just like,
what is happening?
Um,
so yeah,
so I think it's just like,
I just want to get ahead of it.
Don't come.
I just want to get ahead of it cause I don't want to like go into that warm
hole.
Unless you're 20 years old,
you're always going to look old.
It's like,
dude,
I'm not like,
I'm not trying to fool.
Nobody look great.
You look,
you guys took long enough for you to say you're like amazing.
Like amazing.
And you guys,
you guys look great and age appropriate.
It will be,
I don't want to look younger.
I just want to look the age I am.
But I think that what we do is so aging.
Like we're out to one in the morning.
We worked during the day also cause it's like comedy used to be you just to
stand up at night.
Now it's during the day,
you're doing a podcast,
you're writing stuff.
So we have full time jobs and then we go out til two in the morning and then
we're on flights.
I'm just,
I've been dehydrated since 2004 I am just like,
so I just think the stress of what we do is I just try to get ahead of it and
ours term shame,
a lot of inappropriate behavior in public love it.
I love that.
I can not believe came in though because people send us videos of people like
clipping their toenails on planes.
I've seen it at the gate.
I saw this motherfucker,
I've got on a plane recently.
You know,
it's like we've all worked really hard to be able to fly first class.
Like we worked.
I mean I remember days where I was doing 80 cities a year sitting in the back
row in the middle by the shitter.
Like we've done Sam flights.
So yes.
So when I like to take a photo on Instagram,
so it's a go first class.
Like I'm just like,
fuck you dude.
First of all,
this is miles because we travel so much and like I've worked my ass and the
venue pays for like don't do this.
This fish gets on the plane with a bag of hard boiled eggs and I've seen that
before too.
I just went,
no,
it was like get to the back.
I full on,
had to have a conversation.
First Class.
Yes.
Sitting right next to me and I was going to Fort Lauderdale I think and I was
like,
I literally said,
I said to this woman,
yeah,
by poor palm beach bar or something and I was just like,
I've worked too hard.
I've seen it.
I've seen somebody with a bag,
the Ziploc gallon bag and then crack pulling them.
Five of them smell.
No,
it's just,
it's so fucking rude.
This is going to blow your mind.
Julia.
No,
no.
For our audiences listening,
know what?
No way to describe.
This is man who appears
to be in a grocery store.
I,
he is in a grocery store.
He's at the hot food counter and he's using the ladle to serve soup.
He is
drinking from it?
No.
And he looks like he looks like a well put together guys.
That's he looks like.
So those are fancy shoes.
Yeah.
And he's got like a nice sweater bag of buns.
Bread.
What is that?
He's shopping.
It looks like Amy,
by the way,
if no one was in a grocery store,
would we all do that?
He's just doing what we all wish we could tell.
I mean,
I wish I could think in the grocery store straight up.
I agree.
But you buy them,
right?
Like you put them in your separate container and eat them out of your bag.
You're right.
And then I,
yeah,
that's fine.
You're going to pay for those.
But this,
that's a public school.
That's insane.
That is bad.
Is it mental element.
And when I started doing,
when I got pregnant the second time I used to eat at Gelson's at the salad bar.
Yeah,
me too.
And then when I got Prager's I was like,
you know what?
This is a bacteria thing.
It is not safe.
Well,
did you see the um,
wild,
wild country?
That's how they poisoned everybody is they just put,
um,
a salmonella in the salad bars.
Yeah.
And He,
and I intuitively was like,
this will hurt my child.
So I stopped not safe.
And I love the guys [inaudible] cancer.
And when he was going through chemo,
they were like,
no salad bars.
Your immune system is not capable.
Wow.
Yeah.
And I love at the end of salad bars,
there's always like chocolate pudding or like,
I'll do it.
All right.
We've been really obsessed with Garth Brooks and his um,
social media random.
Is it great?
It's so amazing cause stuff,
slick stuff,
neat stuff.
That's him.
But uh,
I just came to our attention because we've been so obsessed with his videos that
another man who's looking to take the title of most Awkward Social Media Guy.
Yeah.
It is the founder and CEO of Facebook,
Mark Zuckerberg.
Really?
Oh,
you guys are eating brisket and ribs tonight.
Brisket and ribs.
They tastes doubly better when I'm,
when you hunted the animal yourself.
So what are your,
what are you guys making for dinner?
Brisket and ribs,
I hope.
Delicious brisket and ribs.
Ribs.
And the brisket need to be eaten.
I want to try your brisket.
I want to try my brisket.
It's a pretty tough cut.
Immediately.
The ribs and the brisket or you're excited to have a rib?
Oh,
well my baby back baby back ribs.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
Okay.
There is the third richest guy in the world.
First of all,
is that his house?
I don't know.
I hope that's his house.
Very expensive girl.
That egg grill.
Yeah,
those are good.
The uh,
the,
it's Mark Zuckerberg for those.
Again,
Mark Zuckerberg was worth like $30 billion.
Why are you even doing videos?
First of all?
Probably.
Why are you apologizing to us?
First of all,
I know,
I'm sure someone at Facebook,
it was like,
you should do this.
It'll make you look human.
Yeah,
that's right.
We've done is Ysu and making it not look like a diabolical while.
That's what they said to Garth Brooks.
They go,
you need to do social media.
And Garth was reluctant and then that's what happens when they don't want to do
it and they're automatons inside.
They're dead inside and they wanted to be relatable and they're not related to,
what did he say?
It tastes better when you kill it yourself.
Does he hunt?
Was that what he was doing?
He was trying to get Rogan's crowd trying to tap into somebody who wrote that to
him and he was like reading the comics.
Looks like he's reading comics.
Oh it's like an Instagram.
Pli.
I own this APP.
I should see how it works.
I love the idea that we can use him as a puppet and just comment on his lives
and he'll do whatever we say.
Really,
really funny.
Like someone went baby back ribs.
He was like,
check this shit out.
Which is that same Garth weird humor response where they're like,
they have like,
like 60 year old dad humor.
You know somebody wrote here man.
Yeah,
that's what I'm talking about.
See that's how I am now.
I have to
get excited.
Instagram lives I now,
it's so exciting when you're first seeing it,
but to them,
I don't do a lot of Instagram lives for that reason cause I just,
I just repeat the comment terrible.
It's bound to it.
I don't really know how I'm supposed to do that.
That's it's endearing.
I haven't seen Garth Brooks this.
Have you seen James Brolin's?
He,
have you seen how he um,
he posted one of just his bare ass and cowboy boots.
Like good for him.
He goes for it and he looks at it and go for it.
He seems like he's,
he's living his best life.
I think a lot of people don't quite know that it,
that it goes to everybody.
You know what I mean?
I feel like a lot of people,
I used to think this,
let's go on to my friends.
You just think it's like a mass text to your friends and then you realize like,
no,
like news reporters following like journalists follow you,
you know?
Um,
yeah.
I was going to put,
I was going to do an Instagram live after that.
That's what's so messed up.
When my guy proposed,
I literally was like,
how are we gonna get a picture of it?
At first my first thought was like,
is there a picture?
How am I need a picture?
And my second thought was say no as a joke.
Oh No,
you're having this reaction.
Cause I was like,
oh my God,
the fact that another common cause I was like,
just say no.
It just go and then be like,
yes,
of course.
And then I was like,
don't do it,
don't do it.
And I like froze like you know how like computers like rebuffering stream.
I was like,
don't,
don't jog.
And then I was crying and I could end,
but it my brain,
I said,
you know,
I was like,
oh should I have done that?
And I asked him,
I was like,
would that have been funny?
And he was like,
I would have doubted this forever.
Yeah,
I had done that.
You Monster,
you have to have a real moment.
I know it just has comedy programming.
I was just like,
oh I should like make a joke out of it.
And then I was like,
there's something wrong.
But like social media and all have like totally toxified my brain.
You know,
it's interesting.
Tommy and I together we have our fun,
like I think behind closed doors we were pretty much the same people,
but we don't joke a lot.
Right.
Really boring usually,
but yeah,
we joke.
We do actually.
Yeah.
No,
we joke a good bit actually,
but I don't know.
I wouldn't say it there.
Do you ever feel like,
do you ever like,
like I find this now with social media because there's just this like pressure
to constantly be posting and like con,
do you,
are you ever like,
oh,
we have to do a thing,
let's just film this.
No,
you never feel like an obligation.
I refrain a lot from social media when I,
when I ain't got shit to say.
I ain't going to say it.
Do you know what I'm saying?
Him?
Yeah.
I fucking care.
It's not interesting to me,
but I know when I,
because I'm obsessed with Instagram,
I actually really enjoy other people's,
yeah.
Yeah.
And you find that it's just the same shit over and over.
Like totally,
here's the dog in me,
here's the sandwich.
Here's the thing.
I literally talking about my feed,
but it's everybody's feeling totally.
I'm like,
I'm just looking at the same shit every day,
but I still like it.
I don't want to just do another thing that other people have to stare at that
they've already seen,
which in turn should that should be the argument from me doing it more cause I'm
like,
oh,
that must be other people enjoy the now right of minutia there just,
we'll go an idiot idiot idiot and you're like,
dude,
I'm going to be another,
I just,
it's like sort of this social media,
like this is the part of the business that I haven't wrapped my head around
because it's such a big tool and I'm so like,
no,
you're great at it.
I think you should give yourself credit because you're very vulnerable and I
would say that is so hard to do on Instagram and brave and great and it's,
it's worked for you.
I think you've,
you've done it.
That's really nice.
I have no idea what I'm supposed to be doing.
It's like I feel,
I don't know.
It doesn't,
but there's some people that I feel like do it well.
You know,
and I'm just like,
I mean,
just the Garth Brooks talking into a thing.
It's just like,
what are your car with bro?
Like what?
Do they have to do it or do they want to do it?
That's always my question.
You should be doing,
you should be on social media.
I had to check off.
Yeah.
I had that conversation with Dmitri Martin the other day because he's just like,
I don't know how to do this,
and I'm like,
dude,
you're perfect for social media and these one liners,
just fill it.
He was just like,
I don't want to be like,
hey guys.
I'm like,
you don't just do it your way.
Garth does let the conversation slicks that.
That's really weird.
Is he touring or it's just for him?
No,
he's torn arena tour.
He's stadium tours.
He's Garth Brooks.
He's crazy.
A Little Dick faggot.
You got a little fucking teeny Derek,
Huh?
Yeah,
but you do.
Yeah.
Your Dick a little,
no wonder you're fucking gay.
That's because you can't please a fucking woman.
Isn't that right?
Some women have a little,
you decided to be a fucking faggot because you can't please a woman.
And I'm sure you've heard,
oh,
is it in yet?
That was cause they can't fucking feel it.
They can't fool your dick cause you're such a fucking loser.
You're such a little fucking little Dick.
You know what's crazy?
He got paid to do.
There's one thing that's crazy about this.
Somebody paid him to do that.
Oh,
I bet they love this.
I bet their psych that this is their new ad.
This guy is,
it's fine to humiliate.
So you,
you hit him up on Skype and you have to pay him and he humiliates you.
Is it like a serve?
It's like a sexual,
like as a fetish shit.
I know I'm really into dominate.
Trick says like,
I could do it.
I feel like I could do for you.
You'd be great at it.
Now I'd be like,
I'm sorry.
No,
I'd be like,
this is a thing that's obviously a trauma happened to you.
All right.
Like this is a maladaptive response.
Here's what I would do.
Master
EA.
But there's something,
um,
I,
I'd be like,
Hey,
can we work on the lightning?
Like I would just terror and horror,
which is why he's perfect for this.
How much money is it?
How much?
I don't know.
Everyone has their own rates and you know,
we don't want to get into their personal business,
but I'm not sure.
I'm not sure what he charges.
But I'd be interested.
Would you,
you could do this.
We do this.
Should I do,
if I weren't married with an a mom,
I would do fart videos.
Cause that's just easy money.
But it's just your,
but have you found the girl that sits on cakes?
Course.
I'll do that.
I can do that.
I could do fart and I could kick guys in the nuts.
No problem.
You could into.
No,
I would.
I would do it for how I've always had started under the answer.
36 years old.
How do you kick someone in the nuts but not the dick.
You have to hold this no practice.
No.
Those nuts will usually like the way that they hang.
If you kick,
you're going to kick the balls.
Dick,
when does your dick her when it gets kicked also,
it's just the nuts part.
Really.
Your Dick doesn't hurt if you get your kicked in the Dick.
It's very,
the way that they lay together.
Your balls are much more sensitive.
Sure.
If you get hit in the balls,
you feel it up inside of your,
your abdominal area and it fucking really hurt.
But your Dick only her like I feel like during sex,
if it jams,
that's the thing that hurts the deck.
Right.
Jams when he called Jama,
know the Dick like if you miss,
you know what I mean?
You can.
You can break it.
You can break a break.
A tech.
Tommy's head is dig broken.
Really?
Yeah.
He's talked about it on stronger like a million years ago.
That's a bummer.
Rodman talked about that.
Oh,
Rodman got his cartilage.
Cartilage.
There's blood vessels that can pop.
That's not great.
I don't think I could fart.
I don't think I could fart in front.
You're not foreign in front of your heart.
No.
Well,
you got to change that right quick.
Our lifetime of holding weird,
but what about when did you get,
when was the first time you got half artists stop at one month and do it?
He put my hand in his crotch and he farted on my head.
That's a month in Whitney.
This is disgust like our whole life is this guy.
I don't think farming's is.
I think it's funny.
I would love to do it with him.
We
just don't.
He's done and in front of me,
but I try to not do it.
Gotta do it.
You got to do it.
Otherwise it's a lifetime of holding.
I remember Howard was saying the key to his relationship,
his,
they have separate bathrooms.
I know he doesn't like it when Beth.
Oh yeah.
They've never talks about pooting.
No.
Well,
what about Angel Angel?
I follow her on Instagram.
We'll talk about yes,
off.
My thing is,
but what about when you have to Brown?
Do you announce it?
What do you do when you're hanging out and you got to go take a brand?
I just pretend I'm,
I'm just,
I pretend I'm doing something else and I spray perfume around the bathroom and I
turned the faucet on.
Yeah.
I just pretend to like,
in his mind,
I've never,
oh wait,
wait,
wait.
But what if it's a hot brown?
What if it's a sick brown?
You've got diarrhea.
I go future.
I tell them like,
oh,
I've got to go get a dry cleaning,
and I go do it at Starbucks.
Yeah.
I just go somewhere and do it somewhere else.
Go somewhere.
Or I'll just be like,
hey,
I have to make this call.
I'll just lie.
I mean,
I feel like a good relationship is built on just lies.
Right?
So that helps me.
Yeah.
I'm like,
I gotta go do this call real quick.
Are you going to be in here for a minute?
All right,
I'm going to go in here.
I'm gonna go take a bath.
That's a big one.
And I just turned on the bath water and just wet my,
I'm like this none in your business.
He doesn't know how to do this.
I'm like,
I have to do this.
I have to call her to talks podcast,
talked to the president of the comedy writing the presence,
show businesses calls.
So you must have,
you must have a few bathrooms in your house.
I'm hoping that like a safe haven I do.
My bathroom is like,
because it's also like I feel like I got this thing in my head a couple of years
ago where people used to say like,
oh yeah,
with the stuff you talk about in your special,
it's just like a deterrent to guys.
So in my head I was like okay,
in my personal life I have to like overcorrect and not do anything polarizing or
whatever.
Cause in my standup I'm like talking about squirting,
you know,
all that kind of stuff.
So it's like,
okay,
like in my personal life I should probably tone it down,
which might not be true,
but it's like a narrative I have in my head.
No,
it's so interesting.
I was just telling Tom about how liberating it must be when you no longer have
to be sexually viable to men.
Like,
imagine how much funnier you're going to be like both of us when we're like
totally barren,
post-menopausal,
just shoplifting.
Fucking what?
Every year.
I'll constantly,
I feel like the reason him and I,
the reason I wanted to be with it,
like I feel like I can just be garbage around him.
She's basically saying,
when you're this lady,
okay,
five residential,
hey,
fuck you.
Both of you,
25 25 residential.
What does that mean
to you?
Fuck you.
Love her.
You love her.
That's why I might be four months away from that shit.
Love that lover or straight to a man.
That's 20 out of 25 is the speed limit.
Yeah.
I don't know.
It was just kind of her like when you're 25 years,
the lover of the fucking dog,
the whole deal that's going to be mean.
You know what's
the fact that quite a lot of breaths on me abusing you.
Oh,
the fact that you're a little fucking little faggot Dick.
I've seen bigger belly buttons.
Then your Dick,
he didn't get the F gt then he doesn't write it out first.
He's got to date and revising my job.
I'd write the insults out.
I think so like a pass.
I was like,
fuck you.
Like you said,
coming up with that,
like prepare for your job.
See how over prepare.
I love it when he's still working all at Gwinnett.
Come from there.
A perfectionist,
like even in the impromptu insults was like,
you don't want to have them in my pocket if someone punches up to business.
I love it.
It's like,
let's make a business out of this.
Let's say this could be a thing.
Um,
just so people can,
where are you?
Where are you going to be?
Oh Gosh.
Um,
I'm doing,
I'm going to Nashville.
I'm going to Salt Lake City.
I'm going to Raleigh and doing the whole deal.
You do it.
Oh yeah,
I'm trying to go to non La,
New York.
I'm trying to go everywhere.
That's where you got intense comics.
It's like when you work in a special,
you can't just go to the,
you know,
places you said flappers I just did two Sunday nights and the you who room in a
row and yeah.
The reason being,
you've got mall people,
these are valley.
That's your normal fucking people.
People who like chain restaurants.
Yeah.
Jail.
If they laugh,
you know you got something.
People that are watching.
It's like you don't just want to be doing comedy for your friends.
I think a lot of times we get so myopic.
Big Word.
These are all knit man.
She's working.
Yeah.
Just add,
added a bunch for January.
Uh,
Whitney cummings.com.
Go see Whitney live.
She's coming to your city.
Bakersfield.
Cleveland.
Oh,
sorry.
That's already part of that was already,
I'm so Sacramento was spoken.
Vegas,
La Jolla.
Salt Lake.
Nashville's Christ.
What a nightmare.
Budget cities stressful.
Um,
see her live by her books.
I don't think I've ever been to Salt Lake City for common.
Right?
Oh good.
Are you doing Sir Greg?
Love wise guys?
Never met.
You're going to have fun.
I totally knew hour.
No politics.
Not One politic or you go zero hero.
It's like,
I feel like people are gonna know that.
You know what I mean?
Smart girl.
Yeah.
It's like,
Nah,
it's over right.
No one wants to hear him.
No one wants to go see comedy and like getting a fight.
I know their spouse.
Anything else,
Jean?
You know,
watch the degenerates.
I am,
uh,
the last one in the lineup and lucky number six,
the number of the beast to watch that,
the ride or die tour,
check out the 2019 dates on Christina p online.
Did the den degenerates.
Just dropped like yesterday the day.
Great.
Um,
and as we mentioned earlier,
this is a rare occasion,
but we're going to take you right now to our in depth conversation with Kate
from below
who was in here.
And
that will be that.
Thank you guys.
We'll see you next week.
Thank you Whitney.
Very much.
It's fantastic.
Best.
Oh God.
You're amazing.
This is so exciting.
We've never been more excited to have a guest ever.
And we must do a proper introduction because whenever we discuss reality,
you know,
it's real.
Yeah.
Hell yeah.
Oh yeah.
Do you want to go ahead and do an introduction?
I am so excited right now.
I mean,
we've had many famous people in studio.
You are by far.
I'm just,
I'm so excited.
I'm so star struck right now to be sitting next to the one and only k Chast
Dayne from below deck.
Ooh.
We've watched you for years.
I feel like we've been watching you for decades and it's only been a few years
working on boats for decades.
But yeah,
it's been a five seasons now.
Five seasons.
For those that don't know,
that are listening,
watching,
we are hardcore fans of below deck.
Uh,
the Bravo TV show that takes you on mega yachts,
super yachts with a full crew of which,
uh,
Kate has,
is a chief's do,
uh,
that's in person.
No.
Yeah.
The person is,
you have to speak to the people that don't know the person in charge of the
interior.
This is service,
uh,
making sure that,
you know,
the rooms are clean and tidy,
make sure everything looks great.
Presentable.
Yeah.
It's like running a boutique hotel.
Exactly.
The ocean.
It's like you're at like a beautiful hotel and you want nothing but impeccable
service.
And what we've discovered first of all,
is that not only did we love impeccable service in real life,
we love watching people,
uh,
deliver impeccable service on reality TV.
And we love watching people who know great service,
uh,
yell at people who don't know how to provide impeccable service.
And you certainly would enjoy below deck.
It's so great.
We're so into it.
And you know,
what I love best about it is that it's kind of like Downton Abbey when you think
that some people have said,
yeah,
didn't it start at this around the same time?
I think that was the original pitch that Bravo had in mind where it's like
Downton Abbey on the ocean.
Yeah.
It makes total sense.
Upstairs,
downstairs world.
That's right.
Yeah,
that's right.
And you end up,
of course,
being much more fascinated by downstairs.
Oh,
that's the thing.
That's where all the good stuff,
that's where all the good stuff happens.
How did you,
okay,
so anybody can obviously check out the show.
You're,
you're going to be into it.
It's so great.
There's so many character.
But like before obviously the show,
you've been working on yachts,
how did it even come about?
How did it start?
My cousin had done it in the 90s which I really respect because there was no
internet.
So once you set out on that boat,
you were like cut off from civilization.
So she would send us postcards every now and then from every different country.
And I was like,
oh,
that sounds cool.
And then after college graduation I was like,
I don't want to get a real job yet.
Yeah.
So I was like,
oh,
I'll just do yachting for one year and then I'll make money and then I'll come
back and you know,
figure it out.
You'll meet your billionaire boyfriend.
Yeah.
Really my plan,
you know?
So I was like,
oh well just,
you know,
float off into the sunset
with a billionaire.
That didn't exactly happen.
But I did end up doing it for like seven years because once you start working on
yachts,
you feel like you've won the lottery.
You have,
it feels like exotic summer camp for adults that are cool,
bunk bed,
shared meal times.
You put a five star chef cooking your food,
you've got no bill of it.
You're all living on this yacht.
Uh,
possession is 90% of ownership.
If the,
if the owners aren't there,
it's your yacht.
You're using their tender to go wakeboarding everyday after work.
It's just feels amazing and then that wears off.
But you feel like you're always chasing that first year dragon.
Well,
here's the thing,
because Tom and I,
every season without fail,
we marvel at how hard you guys work.
And we sit there and we're like,
how do these people do this?
Like you're not sleeping.
Um,
and the exterior has it rough because of the heat and the salt.
And then you guys have it rough because of the drunk people.
He pull your deal also do it.
When you see on a reality show to those cameras are always rolling.
It's like one in the morning doing dishes hates up three in the morning.
It's a lot of work,
but you're stuck on the boat.
So there's not much more to do and you're making such good money that it's kind
of worth it.
Uh,
it taught me a lot about cleaning.
It taught me a lot about laundry and a lot,
I didn't know any of that before I started in boy.
And now my favorite thing to do is iron sheets.
Yeah,
it's so relaxed.
So can you tell it like people,
what kind of money?
So like a first year,
Stuart asked,
I think I started out,
I own 189 foot yacht,
which is pretty big.
So a third to of that size vessel.
But I was making like 2,500 bucks a month.
And that's,
that's not bad.
Learn for young,
but,
but you,
that's all disposable income.
And so then if you're not paying rent,
nothing,
no expenses.
And a lot of times we're in an international waters and they're like
international a bosses.
So then if you're on a charter boat,
on top of that,
you get tips.
So let's say I was on a,
uh,
one 60 foot boat.
I was second stu,
I was making four grand a month.
And then we had a busy charter December where we did like four charters.
So I made about 16,000 and tips.
So in December of 2013 I made 20 grand.
Just all
work doesn't seem as much when you compare it to
let's do dishes,
man.
Yeah.
And you're with a crew that's international,
young,
well traveled.
It's fun when everybody knows how to do their job.
Yachting is actually fun.
It's when you've got the inexperienced people that it becomes less.
How much that a reality of what's happening to you not being,
not filmed.
Like you're out there,
you're working.
How often are you dealing with,
you know,
undertrained pretty often.
No,
I mean,
I think green people start on private boats.
Charter boats are a little bit more,
um,
intense schedule,
a little more demanding.
So usually to get on a charter boat,
you'd have at least a year.
You know what you're doing slightly,
you get it.
What's the difference between a private and a charter?
A private yacht is,
well,
all yachts are owned by somebody so rich that we don't even know who they are.
Like a rush they paid where you can't Google them.
Like Ah,
there's one Russian arms dealer that has a yacht that just goes around the South
Pacific and they,
he never visits and I'm pretty sure he's just got something on that boat that
he's keeping moving.
Yeah.
So my friends on the made on that belt,
he's got a great life.
Um,
and so a lot of time to offset the cost of these yachts because just to keep it
running a year is about $4 million budget with staff and with cleaning supplies.
So to offset that cost,
they'll charter,
they'll rent it out for weeks at a time.
Cause that's what we noticed.
It seems like constant cleaning.
The exterior crew is wiping that boat down 24 seven that's job security for sure
for us.
But it is such an expensive vessel.
And I would always feel guilty when the owners weren't,
well not that guilty,
but if the owners weren't visiting,
I'm like,
Gosh,
there's paying me like hanging on their boat.
But I've worked on boats that tried to cut corners and didn't have a full time
crew and with something that expensive as an investment,
well not really an investment,
but if you spend that much money on a boat,
you want it to stay in good condition.
Now I was just up last night reading my favorite book.
Oh low Kate chestain lucky,
charming.
And what struck me about you a or a fantastic writer,
you're very funny.
It was just this the first of all,
that's why we love you.
Your commentary is so funny on this show and what I've always admired about you
is that you're never afraid to be who you are.
And I think especially as women,
society has us being polite all the time and smiling and you know,
get it,
get it.
And you were so refreshing because,
and I hate using the word the resting bitch.
Right?
Then you're not a bitch.
You're just a fucking person doing your job.
You're busy.
Yeah,
that's a little busy over here and their whole resting bitch face thing.
I had never really thought I had it before.
I was using that as a defense for the rocket ship.
Lincoln.
I made it.
I was like a moment of panic because I thought like diversion,
you know,
just say something and uh,
it,
it's turned out.
It's kind of true though.
And I have a resting bitch face.
Well I just think you're a person who likes what they do.
You're very professional.
Um,
but what struck me as interesting is that you come from kind of a fancy pants
background,
right?
Not really.
I mean,
I went to private school,
but it's not that fancy.
Um,
but I,
I do enjoy high end service.
Like I really do love it.
I love being dressed up.
I love jazz lounges.
I like the finer things in life.
So my dad offered to get me a new car when I was in college.
If I majored in nursing because he wanted to make sure I would have a good job,
but I can't do it.
I can't even watch Grey's anatomy.
So I want a job that's going to have some element of fun to it.
Like being in our,
she probably never like this was a fun day,
but like in high end service there's like people celebrating and having a great
time and that's why I've always kind of loved that area.
Okay.
Cause I was thinking like,
oh is she came,
I was just trying to think of how shocking it must have been free of the first
time you worked on a yacht and you're like,
oh my God,
like I'm really working.
This is really hard.
Yeah.
That was a big shock because when I went to go work on my first shot,
I packed my suitcase and I was like,
I don't know where aviator sunglasses and a scarf around my neck.
And my friend was like,
yeah,
if they let you,
I didn't realize how much of the help I would be.
Yeah.
But we had an engineer on board and he brought his dog on board while we're at
the dog.
And one day I was cleaning up after the engineer's dog.
That was my job.
I was below a dog in the hierarchy.
So that was a real wake up call.
It was a tough adjustment.
How big of an adjustment was that?
Fuge well,
it wasn't easy,
but the good thing about the Yod is once I got the job on the boat,
that taught me everything.
We're in the middle of the ocean so I couldn't really escape if I wanted to.
I was kind of forced to evolve,
but I'm thankful for it.
Yeah.
So
it's,
um,
yeah,
it's uh,
I'm,
I'm so fascinated by the wheel.
I'm also somebody that I feel like I really appreciate,
appreciate great service and it,
it kind of like really gets under my skin when I'm somewhere and not getting,
especially if you're somewhere where it should happen,
you know,
like you go to a nice hotel and you're like,
the fuck is going on here with the front desk and no one's answering the phone
when you call and you're like,
hey,
I can fortunately that you're hiring a bunt and like,
it's not that I'm a,
I feel like I'm super demanding,
but I also feel like,
you know,
I would be,
if I was the person working,
I would be trying to give great service to the guest.
It bothers me cause it would,
I wouldn't do it.
I'm not high maintenance,
but I do like things that are fair.
Yeah.
I were entering this contract that we're,
I'm going to pay top dollar for a fine experience that I expect them to deliver
that.
Yeah.
And I also like,
it's also why like if somebody,
I don't know even talks to you shitty,
you're like,
Yo,
I,
I treat everyone with respect.
So the moment I feel like I'm not being treated with respect.
Yeah.
It just makes my blood boil.
You know,
now at a restaurant,
will you complain or will you know what I do?
I feel bad.
I don't complain to the restaurant.
I don't complain to the server.
I put whoever I'm dining with.
I feel so bad because I'll be like,
thank you so much.
And then they'll walk away.
I'd be like,
God,
this is horrible.
I'm like,
I don't punish the people.
I don't punish the server.
I'll comment about it like after they leave and I won't be happy,
but I am not where there's people that sends things back or anything.
One time I just some things back because if it,
if it's inedible and that's on the shadow when you have to be like,
dude,
I had to,
sorry,
one time I was actually in Florida,
like a nice steak house and I asked her something medium rare and it was like
clearly well done and like,
Hey,
oh I sent it back and you know what?
They brought out a fully like raw piece of meat and I was like,
okay,
yeah.
I was like,
but I wasn't a dick about it.
I was just like,
Hey,
this is definitely not medium rare.
And then they were like,
here's a raw piece of beef.
And I was like,
okay.
And I didn't make it a thing again.
I was like,
I took a couple bites and I was like,
oh,
I'm full.
Thank you very much.
So I don't know,
one time I did do something out of emotion
where I got like kind of disrespected by a restaurant.
So I put up a post on my Instagram and told them to leave negative Yelp reviews
and they did a thousand a thousand.
I love this kind of stuff.
I like a creative payback,
you know,
to just random people.
But if you like slight me,
I love a creative.
Oh it was great because I think people destroyed their Yelp and then the
restaurant figured it out called the comedy club that I had been working at that
week and they're like,
we want to talk to him.
And they were like,
he doesn't work here.
He's a comedian that passed through and so they couldn't figure it out.
Eventually though Yelp figures out if something is like spammed,
they fix it.
But yeah.
But it was very satisfying.
Review Yourself.
No,
I don't have a profile.
I don't even know.
I don't even have the APP.
I've tried to even like look at a restaurant I like looking at.
The only time I did is when I got an infection from a pedicure salon and I was
like kind of a health thing.
You got to be protected.
The other people,
that doesn't happen.
That's really the only time I will or a positive.
Super Positive.
Oh,
the people,
you know,
there's a couple of things get,
there's so much stuff that we were like obsessed with on the show.
One thing that,
so many questions on,
I think you touched on it,
we don't even went back.
We started watching season two because it was,
it looks like a documentary compared to like what does like so much raw,
more raw and rough,
but I love it because we didn't know what we were doing with the show.
Like I had no idea.
I was just there to be [inaudible] before.
No,
no,
no.
Because he has that great line when he goes,
shit,
he goes,
a k looks like she should be chartering the Ui.
That was really,
really nice.
Well,
that's another thing that happens when you work on yachts.
This is why I don't have as much money saved from all those great charter tips
as I should because you're around the most wealthy people on the planet and you
start seeing what,
how they live and your tastes kind of automatically.
You want to live like they do.
So when you have time off,
you're like,
well,
I made all this money but I work hard.
I deserve to live like them.
So it's like traps you.
She says Birkin bag.
That's what,
no,
I would never do that.
Know that's took the month of December,
2014 all of it.
Yep.
No,
I would never,
I mean I would,
I'd forgotten she tells,
but Perkins are crazy.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
How much are they?
I don't even know.
Hey,
that started like a car.
Okay.
Yeah.
No,
I like Chanel.
That's good enough,
right?
Yeah.
Coco,
no.
Come on.
You mentioned this.
How often does it happen?
You mentioned,
I think it's on the recent season,
the fear of the verbal,
the verbal tip that happens in service as well.
When someone's like,
you did such a good job.
It's like,
no,
no.
Oh No.
Cause they're like,
I want you to know.
I appreciate too,
because I also know that I'm not going to tip you because I'm cheap.
Does that feel good?
Yeah.
It's an overcompensation for what?
They're not going to do almost fuckers insult
to injury.
It's like,
now I can't even be mean to you,
like hate you because you're so nice
and I've paid enough.
So anyway.
Yeah.
So if like,
here's what I'm curious about.
So on the show,
you know,
people are obviously chartering for a couple days,
but typically somebody goes on a charter,
a yacht,
a,
it's for a week,
I think is the standard time,
right?
Let's look at,
yeah.
So what is the standard for like,
I've looked up and I've seen,
you know,
that you can charter these yachts,
these super yachts,
mega yachts for hundred,
200,
300,000.
It's crazy money.
What is the industry standard for tipping?
Is it a percentage of that?
It's 20% it's 20% fuck in a
day's work.
So that's how I made all the money in December 13th.
So let's say the boat,
uh,
it was $150,000 for the week,
and that doesn't include fuel food.
They're going to spend $200,000 minimum for their seven day vacation.
But also they give something called an Apa and advanced provision allowance
where they send us thousands of thousands of dollars to shop for other champagne
and lobster and oysters and all their food.
And a lot of times we don't use all of that money.
So what they'll do is they'll Tibet's 20% on $150,000,
which is $30,000 divided by 10 crew.
So you've got three grand there and then they'll say,
and you can have the rest of the APA,
so you'll make,
yeah.
So we'll just figure it out.
They're like,
well,
yeah.
So,
uh,
because,
because after seven days of the best service on the planet,
they are just so blissed out of their mind.
They're like,
take it all.
We don't.
We thank you.
Oh,
because seven days is a long time to be on a boat with these charter guests.
And by the end of it,
your friends is seven days.
The typical length,
seven days is the minimum.
Um,
I've had charters that stayed on board for a month.
No.
Yeah,
I didn't say God damn fortune.
Yes,
there they were rushing this group.
But,
um,
a lot of the Russians,
how have the big yeah and the middle end.
Any Middle Eastern I there are but they have the biggest,
biggest,
biggest boats.
Like they almost like compete with each other.
There are these two sheikhs who were like competing.
They don't tell a how big their building their yacht cause they don't want them
to like outdo them.
And then there was one sheikh who like had finally built the biggest yacht.
He stepped foot on it for the first time and he's like I feel too far away from
the ocean,
sell it.
Like they just have stupid money but that size boat I don't like working on,
I don't like working on anything over than 200 feet cause then we're getting
into like small cruise ship and it's just,
it's just nuts.
The ideal.
What's the best size?
I love a 180 which is 60 meters and that is usually around 14 crew.
It's big enough where you don't get sick of your crew members.
There's enough people personalities to bounce off of,
but it's not so many that you feel like you're just a cog in a wheel.
It feels like.
So like a family and it's big enough to for the guests to feel like there's
plenty of rooms to go to and it's just you're going to get hired tip money cause
it's going to cost more.
The bigger the boat.
So one eighties the real sweet spot and that's what happens to be the size of
the boat that we used on this season of below deck and Tahiti and cry or she
isn't even using like one fifties which is also a great size,
but then you go to 60 meters and that's kind of like perfect.
Which brings me to the next question perfectly.
A lot of the previous seasons,
and I think most of the time like I'm from Florida,
so you're just exposed to the Caribbean.
Huge difference between working in the Caribbean and Tahiti.
Honestly not so much on the boat,
especially for me.
Like,
oh look,
another palm tree out the porthole.
Yeah.
You know,
but the only difference really is the language barrier because I don't speak
French,
Polynesian or French at all.
I would like to,
but um,
it was a lovely change cause I've done the Caribbean so many times that this was
at least new,
a new location and made it exciting for me.
But at the end of the day,
if you're not getting off the boat,
you're not truly experiencing the places that you're going as much.
Like a lot of Yachty's worked for bragging rights,
but that's all bs.
Like they're like sending photos home to mom and their friends on Facebook.
I look,
oh just in Cannes and Capri and yeah,
when really it should be like day 47 everyday.
A truck struggle,
like,
you know,
so let me ask you one,
I love the preference sheet meeting.
So captain Lee's sits down with Kate and who else?
The boson and the chef.
Yes.
And comes the preference sheet,
which is a photograph of the,
the primary,
which is like the lead guest.
It's his,
her hair party.
Crazy friends to bring.
Yeah.
Are they paid the most?
They get the biggest room that,
oh,
is that right?
Okay.
I have no idea.
It was this banana.
So,
and then there's a list of like things they like,
things they don't like.
Um,
and there've been guests who were southern and we're like,
we don't lack vegetables or fruits.
And Chef Ben was like,
are you being serious?
Like horrified.
Right.
Chicken fingers.
It's just such a funny contrast to have that chef cause he's so posh.
You know that guests like we miss chef man is hilarious.
He's,
he's a genius.
His Dad actually wrote that book,
Lone survivor that was made into a movie.
So what fun fact.
Yeah.
He's his dad's in New York Times bestseller with a lot of military books.
Um,
so Ben Ha grew up a very posh and,
but he is a genius and he's self made after he left home.
I'm like,
he's so,
such a good chef.
We basically watched the show.
It's entertaining,
it's traumatic.
And then what it is is you,
you go into fantasy land of like,
here's what I would do.
And then we plan out.
Then like we're always like,
oh yeah,
whatever you want,
fucking blow our minds.
Let's have four.
Cause we like restaurants.
You got fries.
And he was like,
I can make some fries.
Can I get some grilled cheeses,
cheeses.
And I kind of get it cause I do love it.
But you never think of it.
Both one orders,
grilled cheese and then he's kind to make
10 marks.
That's a good idea.
And that's when it really starts sending them off.
I mean I get just a grilled cheese after you've been drinking too.
It's like that's the thing
now.
But uh,
okay.
So here's Tom,
here's what we're going to do on our charter.
Let's make it happen.
Oh my God,
we've already come on,
here's what worked.
Here's what we're not going to do any kind of themed night,
no parties.
You know what?
I respect that and that.
Not that you guys are elegant because it's like,
here's an idea for a theme party.
A yacht vacation is not good enough.
It makes me well bonkers because he don't do that shit for people that don't
know what happens is a lot of times people come on and then they'll give their
food preferences and we want to have a beach picnic.
And by the way,
we'd love for one night to be,
uh,
to be like a frat party night.
One toe goes,
oh,
okay.
And then it will be like,
you know,
we have a,
it's an all white party.
So random.
I think sometimes it's like,
well,
on a blue and white party with a fiesta sub theme.
I'm like,
what is this?
What is this?
I think on regular charters were there for seven days.
The guests can get a little bit bored.
So towards the end of it you'll be like,
okay,
it's casino night,
Gary Monaco like pirate night because you're on the ocean.
But other than that,
the theme parties or like Gilding the lily.
Sure.
Almost holding you back from having the best experience because now we've got to
serve your tacos because you wanted a fiesta.
I totally agree.
I liked.
I mean,
I want it to be,
I want to chill hard,
great food all the time.
Maybe do massage,
you know,
I could see like,
oh,
I've been laying around.
If there's a gym on board,
I'll do a little workout read.
Yeah,
watch a movie.
I don't know,
just,
I like to relax.
You sound like the ideal charter I guess.
And that's,
you've got great taste.
Now I do want to know what you want to do a beach party cause I don't really
understand why not.
I do hate doing them because it's so much training for iron man,
like dragging these heavy to tell people what that means.
So what happens is the,
the yacht is anchored.
You can't pull a huge yacht up to the shore.
So what happens is the guest goes,
we want to go over to that beach that we see over there and eat lunch on that
beach.
You have to prepare everything.
Two hours to transport on tenders.
The food that the tent,
the tables,
the chairs,
salt and pepper butters,
bug spray,
toilet paper,
forks and Napkins,
condom mitts.
Uh,
ice that melts in the Orient.
We usually in a very hot location,
I've got bring bags.
It's just such a thing.
It never looks cool.
I don't even like outdoor eating me either.
Uh,
every,
every restaurant that go.
Do you like indirect indoors?
You have a luxury yacht but you want to go eat in Sanoe.
Why do you want like I could see saying,
hey,
can we take the tender over to the beach and hang out?
Then we'll come back for lunch.
Eat on board.
See,
I just don't understand why they didn't want to the beach picnic.
Uh,
I would like to keep the sand away from my food.
Absolutely.
Yeah.
I think it's gross and I don't like,
I mean,
I don't know.
I just picture it just flies and it's hard.
People are sweating.
It's just weird.
I don't like it at all.
You know?
Is it true that whenever you anchor and you know it's like it's day three,
should the deck crew have all the toys out immediately?
Yes.
Really?
Actually I
feel like we have to keep informing people.
So tell what that means.
I've got an interior crew.
The tech crew handles like all the Washington,
the boat and the toys for the charter gas,
which will usually be about two jet skis and a trampoline that floats.
They've got so many random,
he just fell off as all tries to close.
Okay.
I talked to him.
You talked to him.
He's like,
okay,
I'm okay.
He's fine.
He doesn't have a bump raining.
Um,
no.
He's talking about toys.
The toys icicle yet we don't,
I mean the toys look fun,
but it's also,
here's the bummer since again for you guys,
but I guess it's part of the price is a lot of times I imagine this set
everything up and people are like,
I just feel like laying down,
right?
Like I don't really want to use it.
They are paying so much money.
If everything is in the garage,
they're never going to use that.
We shouldn't make the guests feel like we're their birding us and everything
should look effortless.
Like the jet skis are there if you want them or if you don't,
it shouldn't be like them asking,
do you think you don't mind?
You know,
getting the jet skis out.
That's right.
That's why every time we dropped the anchor,
put it all out and make money.
Yeah.
I don't know if I do the toys.
We were just talking when you're in there.
I don't want a beach picnic.
No Way.
Never.
Why?
Yeah.
I'm a goddamn boat bathing suit.
Sunbae drink champagne to even discuss this stuff.
That's the fun thing.
I know.
I love it.
It's wild.
Here's what,
here's what I wouldn't do either.
I'm not dressing up fancy dress.
You guys are so cute.
You have the same preferences.
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's my yacht.
I'm going to come up in my pajamas and you guys are going to make me an amazing
meal and I'm going to go lay down again.
Please.
No,
we need a little more scratch.
God dammit.
No.
Maybe.
How old are we?
Maybe in 10 years,
maybe in 10 years we'll do it and not send,
what's his name?
The college doesn't need to go to school.
Right.
So,
so what Yachty weirdest thing you've seen on a preference sheet.
That was some bitch that I think on below Deck Med ed white gumballs.
And that was ridiculous.
I'm embarrassed for you lady.
Yeah.
I mean,
how do you have friends?
If you met somebody in real life that like white gumballs,
you'd be like,
oh look,
here comes some crazy white gumball girl.
Did anybody ask why white
five?
Like you shouldn't be eating that shit.
What was it?
Was
it this season two was so gross?
Cucumber,
ovaries.
What?
The Timothy Sykes Penny stock trader gun.
Yeah,
that one had like molecular just verification,
which I get is cool.
Like it's Mary Thomas Keller.
Um,
a little difficult on a yacht,
but okay.
Uh,
you want a cucumber over?
He said,
I've never heard of that and I can't.
Yeah,
that doesn't sound like you'd be a good texture.
No cucumber over
there was the guy who had that little dime piece with him.
Blondie,
could you go ahead?
And she was like super rude and snappy.
Do remember he's an older guy,
was this last season and she was like,
Hey,
f a f.
I mean,
and then also it's like,
it's always great when a man has to tell his lady of any age.
He'd dial it back down,
calm down.
What are you talk?
Is this your daughter?
I'm not sure you guys are going to last the long haul.
You know?
Know
how unattractive she becomes.
Like she's this beautiful girl started out right away.
When she left she was like negative 10 that's so sad.
It makes people so ugly.
It was the hottest.
People are gross.
I don't like,
she was rude to,
I don't care if it's the parking attendant,
fucking captain,
whoever it is like,
dude,
don't be like that.
Don't be shitty to people.
So,
okay,
so cucumber,
ovaries,
and then what?
I know I don't like the foam party guy.
That's disgusting.
Yeah.
He had so many requests and he invited us all out to his mansion in Acapulco and
I wouldn't mind going to a mansion in Acapulco.
Then I went to air force like $1,000 and I was like,
I'm not paying $1,000 to go goes.
Yeah.
And what is the deal with the film party?
He just hammered all day,
all day.
So hammered and hammered he dumb fucking jacket and hat,
like trying to be like,
I'm that guy,
look at me.
Okay Steve at,
Gosh,
it was just so exhausting and I'm surprised he likes him.
Lee likes going to acapulco
and Captain Leah has gone out there with them a few times and apparently he's
not at all like that when he's in his own home.
You know,
I think he's just trying to make the most of is two days,
three days on the boat.
Um,
but I blame captain leaf for him coming back this season and being like
emboldened because now he was like,
I'm friends with Lee.
I can act however I want,
but at least up in the wheelhouse and I had to deal with,
I'm like,
I didn't go to Acapulco.
You can handle your friend.
He's such an archetype.
Stereotypical what a boat captains should be.
What's his,
what's his history?
How do you become a big,
he actually got into it late in the game I think.
Yeah,
he's kind of a real colorful past like he was working in the steel field mines
or something really north and then see that.
Then like him and his wife were like,
you know,
let's go out of the rat race.
And they went to run a restaurant and like the virgin islands like just picked
up everything went down there,
let's hope it works out.
Didn't really work out that well.
So he started just working on boats because they were in the Caribbean and then
one thing led to another.
He realized there was good money but you didn't start till was like 35 employee.
Absolutely trust that guy.
Like I would,
I feel comfortable and Captain Sandy I like,
I like me some Campton San I take her to,
she's very nice.
She's very nice and I love her.
No,
but she stopped by my hometown and I took her out to dinner and I just say meet
and compare notes and she was lovely.
I just love also how opposite Captain Sandy and Katherine Leon for below Deck
Mad.
It would have been difficult for any male captain to come in and even,
you know,
compare to captain late cause he studied the seas gold jewelry.
He looks like the training from the jewelry.
I know,
I love it.
So much.
Jeans Bracelet.
I mean it's so much gold.
So real Florida,
Florida man.
That's what I'm saying.
He's such as archetypes.
Show me,
show me a picture of him with that on.
I'd be like immediate.
That'd be like the keys like that guy lives in Kuwait.
Yeah,
that's definitely south Florida.
There is an aesthetic.
The Floridians definitely know.
You know what I like about captain lead to his,
his dread of dining with the guests that always,
I'm like I totally get it.
Fuck,
but they pay so much and I secretly enjoy it because the bulk of the time he
gets to hide up in the wheelhouse while I'm stuck with all these Yahoos.
So I'm like here you go captain late like loving it.
I got another specific question cause we went back to season two because we were
so excited about this was it was Andrew,
that was his name.
I think Sandra God,
was he putting us on like was he's just trying to get on TV?
I mean,
yes,
I think so.
But also I don't think he's the brightest.
Oh really?
Okay.
In case you didn't notice.
I mean a lot,
that's what's difficult about the job.
A lot of people want to be on TV,
but this is a safety thing.
We need trained Yachty's because he seemed like he was like,
I'm smiling a lot.
That's cool.
Right?
I'm like,
what are you,
what are you doing?
He thought,
I think he thought he could get away with it.
But if you don't know,
if they've never worked on a yacht,
you're like,
how hard can it be?
Like I was on my first shot,
but I wouldn't want to try that on TV.
You know,
new.
That's going to be embarrassing.
It's probably not gonna end well.
Ask all the green people throughout the seasons.
You know,
I almost feel like when we went back to it,
cause I actually at first I started watching,
I was like man,
cause you know it's been a few years and I was like,
oh wait,
I saw this season,
I thought I'd forgotten so much.
But then when I saw the,
the rocket ship,
that's the best episode of the first big moment of the show.
You guys,
I don't know,
it was like I don't put it in planet because he really didn't play this at all.
I've never done anything like that in my life.
I've never made a rocket ship.
And I always tell people though listening,
what happens.
Okay.
So it's like there's a guest on board and there's only like our second charter
or something.
So it's only been a week on this boat.
I don't really know people that don't know me that well,
like my crew and I'm just doing as good a job as I can.
I'm concentrating and this yes,
as I look bitchy and that they would like me to make some drinks and to be told,
you look bitchy and then to make drinks.
And then forced to smile is just,
it was shocking.
And,
uh,
I only cry when I'm frustrated and I was so frustrated because as we can
humiliated and then told to work,
so I was like,
I'm on TV,
I'm not going to cry.
I'm going to get through this.
So I make the shots,
I bring them out.
I may get there a whole dinner service that night.
I go to bed that night thinking,
good job Kate,
you didn't let the man get you down.
Then the next morning I go to check the turndowns and I just plan on making an
anchor like I usually do so that people know what what you're saying though,
it's that there's guests,
they're out of the room.
So now they're having breakfast and you do things with the towels,
finishing touches.
So I usually make an anchor out of the throw blanket on the bed and while I'm in
there,
you know,
I like a creative payback and the rage was still inside me and hadn't been
addressed.
So I was like creative outlet and I thought a middle finger was my first idea.
But I,
that sounds complicated.
I don't know how to do that.
I don't know how to translate.
Well,
I have a towel.
It's not the right medium.
So in fun fact,
a rocket ship,
a Phallic rocket ship,
it's not that far off from an anchor.
You just put the top together and went to fluff up the bottom.
And so I made it and,
but he was,
there is no cameras,
no nothing.
And I was just playing around.
I wasn't really planning on keeping it,
but when I saw it I was like,
oh that's really good.
I just like,
well he was rude.
So I left and then people saw it and freaked out.
I thought they would laugh.
They were not laughing.
That guests really was not laughing.
No one was laughing.
What did we,
the deck,
the,
my crew thought that we weren't going,
it tipped cause it was pretty disrespectful I guess.
But uh,
no.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It looks like a big penis.
Has he had acted like a dick to me.
He's gay.
That's what I'm just going to say.
He is a gay man.
So
you're providing service things,
more things.
Do you like reference sheets?
Does a theme party and so like,
oh,
of course.
Fabulous.
Yeah.
So they wanted to fire me like really did until now it's week one.
I'm like,
oh my God,
what have I done?
I have just made a huge dick on a bed on national TV.
My mother,
my the way for the first time working with Lee.
Yeah.
So he's like,
yeah,
I thought they would like it cause you know,
for ratings,
whatever,
they did not like it.
Everyone didn't like it.
No,
no one likes.
It didn't as I remember,
cause we didn't get the,
uh,
through the whole thing on season two is,
but in my memory,
didn't he eventually go like he loved and then he came back,
he came back around and now I visited him in Scottsdale.
Yeah,
we're fine.
He finally got it.
But uh,
it,
it was a real scary couple of hours in a day.
I thought I had just ended my career on national television.
Embarrassed my family be a plane ticket.
I did.
Yeah.
But,
uh,
it turns out not so much.
Oh,
may I ask you and I,
it's like a production question to the the plane ticket and the envelope.
Real stuff or production stuff.
Yeah.
Well I don't think,
I don't think they actually get the printout boarding pass.
Oh No,
no,
but is that a practice?
I'm saying no,
I've never gotten one.
Um,
from captain lead,
like I don't know what's actually in that envelope but being fired.
Yeah.
I've been fired a few times on yachts and she discusses it in her book.
Lucky.
Charming.
Yes.
Okay.
Chestain available according to my resume.
Thank you.
According to my resume,
I don't put that I was fired.
I just say that boat was sold because if they sell a boat,
the crew has gets a payout and you go to find another boat.
So I've haven't been fired,
but I have been on about three boats that sold.
What was your,
um,
you know,
what was the reason that they were asking you to leave on a yacht?
You can fire people for any reason,
even if they just don't like you because,
oh yeah.
It's like showbiz captain.
Oh yeah.
Make your shot.
Didn't like me and I don't really blame them because I wasn't used to working
hard.
Like I'd be down the line drawing,
painting my fingernails,
like I just did not get it.
And um,
when you have such tight living quarters,
like one person that doesn't get it can throw it all off and they're just like,
you go figure it out and when they fire you,
it's aggressive.
Cause usually when you get fired from a real job,
you're not,
you're unemployed but you're not also homeless,
so,
right.
You get fired from a yacht.
You could be in a foreign country and now you're unemployed and you're like,
now what?
Yeah,
that's what she writes about in his book is that they didn't,
they dock you somewhere horrendous.
Freeport Bahamas,
which just looks like Satan ship yard.
I'm pretty sure you shouldn't get off the boat without a tetanus shot.
Um,
and that's where the hard hat,
and I'm like,
finally,
after a month of work,
I'm like,
Ooh,
a day off in Bahamas.
And they're like,
ah,
you're fired.
You have one hour to pack in the capital been here.
And it's just like,
Holy Shit.
Yeah.
I had a question from all of these,
uh,
charges you've been on.
Has it chef ever been sick?
I've had chefs not be sick but lose their mind because all chefs are insane.
Yeah.
And they are,
they just are.
It's like to work in that heated environment and creative and they have to like
that rush.
You have to be little nuts.
So I did have a chef that were anchored off Saint Barts with owners on board and
he went to get provisions,
but he told the grocer to keep a bottle of vodka in the freezer.
So it's like 10:00 AM he's slamming alcohol.
He comes back to the yacht hammered.
He's throwing chicken breasts against the gallery wall laughing.
And we had to keep the guests on the Sundeck and fire and tender them off.
Yeah.
And then how hard is it to replace someone like that quickly?
It's got to be,
when you're in a yachting hub,
there's usually one on shore that you can bring on real quick.
Right.
So when you dock,
they're all,
and everyone drinks a bunch.
You're writing about that drinking culture to work hard,
play hard.
I mean it's an industry of people that worked hard.
They want to blow off steam and they got money to spend and yeah.
You know,
Oh,
I wanted to ask you about this.
Um,
you mentioned that you try not to cry on charter,
especially in front of cameras.
Um,
there seems to me to be a theme on the show of fucking cry babies who for
whatever reason breakdown and call their fucking mommy's all the time and cry
about like rocky was a notorious,
we cry baby mommy call her right to keep Rocky's mother's phone number,
the dry erase board because that's how many breakdown she had.
Like it was like speed dial at Rocky's mom,
here's her number,
where I need that tomorrow again.
Yeah.
Um,
I just don't get it.
Uh,
this,
I don't get the confusion like you signed up and if they say they haven't
watched the show,
they're lying or they're stupid.
Like there's no excuse for you to come in at this point and not know what to
expect.
And also you're getting a lot of money,
a lot of tip money.
Is it too much for me to ask that you,
you know,
do the job as well?
Well they don't seem to understand that there's work involved.
And then what does it matter what the chiefs do is doing?
Like what does it matter if what your doing has nothing to do?
Like you give them the order.
And it always bothers me when they're like,
well what is Kate doing?
It's like,
bitch,
it's not of your fucking,
yeah,
she's your boss.
Your boss is like,
go do this.
Like what are you doing boss?
You would never do that in real life.
But I think it's because you live with them.
You must feel like we're more roommates than coworkers or subordinates.
You know,
it blurs the line for people who don't haven't done it a lot.
And I'll admit when I was a second stu,
I thought the chief,
so I was like,
oh,
don't be such a such a good chief.
Do,
how hard can it be?
And then I got my first chief Stu job and I wrote an email to my cheese to that.
I've been real sassy too.
I was like,
Mia Culpa.
I am so sorry.
This is way harder.
I didn't realize there's a lot of stuff that you know.
I think that's with any work,
you don't know what the boss above you is doing.
I think it's a good thing though because I've seen this,
I mean most on your show and like other work environments where somebody goes
like,
there won't be really a hierarchy here and that's a problem.
You should set up the hierarchy.
Yeah,
yeah,
of course.
It's not because I want to boss you around.
It's because we need structure to get things done.
Otherwise it's going to be a free for all.
Here's the reality show experience that we have.
Just so you know.
Oh yeah.
Oh,
thanks.
The hair,
man.
That was the late nineties there's Chadwick who still keep in touch.
Oh my God.
This is why I may have false.
This is the first mission.
Look how skinny I was.
You have a permit frog tattoo.
Oh
stamp before they were called tramp stamps.
I got it in Australia on the show.
I'm embarrassed,
right?
Yes.
Oh yes.
I worked on this.
I mean when I say worked on,
I was in post on the episode,
it says,
put your hands down.
He says Shimmy.
She might go in here and
he or she goes,
do you have your assignments?
Slept.
It went very viral and that was,
she really
did.
She asked if she believed that God.
Oh,
she comes to staff.
It could be a Jew and believing
that and stop.
Yeah.
See
the entire house is dark side.
It's Dork.
She is dark Saturday.
Oh my gosh.
Do you ever have one of those on your charter?
I mean rocky was close to that.
Yeah,
a little no money.
A little less.
Oh my God,
this is tainted.
It's a check.
What are on the show?
Oh she's mad at production right now.
She's mad at the whole thing cause they,
they traded families and she went to see Goosey,
like everything's cool house.
And that lady was in her house.
So she's like,
you know,
she,
she was a Christian.
She was in our house and she hated the whole,
it was all evil.
Everything was the devil.
And she's like,
I'm a god
warrior.
Yes.
Where is she now?
Love to know.
Just be surprised if she were alive.
But yeah,
she um,
I remember when those tapes came in cause I was working as opposed coordinator
on this episode and you know,
that's when we would send out a pa just to fly to the location,
pick up the physical tapes because now things are probably digitized.
And so back then you had a flight pick up the tape and that person would
literally board a plane just with tapes and these tapes came in and I was
working the late shift and one of the editors was like,
you guys got to fucking see this.
Yeah,
we,
we all go in there and we're like,
oh shit.
And everyone knew immediately.
Like this is going to be huge because it's basically what you want somebody
losing their mind.
Yeah.
It's the best reality on network TV.
Sun Rolls
back in the day,
we weren't,
they weren't casting nuts yet.
Like we weren't genuine.
They're cast.
Here's what happened.
Mary Alice [inaudible] of Buna Marie,
she came from a soap opera background.
So her casting decisions were based on finding interesting people,
not crazy people.
I like that.
Yeah.
And I think that's why below deck is so successful.
You've got a good mix of both.
Well,
especially this season.
We've got a great mix of intense personalities,
but none of them are like off crazy.
It's like fun.
Crazy.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah.
I guess road rose is kind of similar to below deck and then close spaces.
How did,
yeah,
she's,
you love it.
I liked it a lot and they had origins.
We all the time and now my nerd it,
I liked it cause yeah.
You traveled.
How did you broke or so back in the day,
they filmed for full months,
so now in the real world used to film for like five months,
but now they've got that little shows cancel.
But they got the show down to like a month maybe.
Yeah.
But we didn't always sleep.
Stay in the Winnebago.
That was a production thing.
They just made it look like we did.
We stayed in youth hostels a lot,
but we're all in the same room like walking together.
It was super cute.
What a good life.
It was great man.
Nobody,
we didn't,
we fought but nobody hooked up.
Of course it was innocent.
And you were in Australia.
Yeah.
And you did a tour around Australia for two months.
Yeah,
it was great.
I was what,
21 years old and I got to see another country and you know,
be on MTV and it was like I want to share.
Sure.
Right.
And then you did the challenge.
I did one challenge in Jamaica and I was miserable.
I had a nervous breakdown by day two.
I was like I can these people.
Cause by then it was the nut bags.
They had cast tense.
Yeah.
I don't like that shit.
Also,
I don't think I would ever like to be on a reality show.
What's a competition?
Uh,
top chef or like a project underway or terrible drag race.
The competition of it all.
I don't like it stress me out so much that I will maybe eliminate it on national
television like that.
You're setting yourself up for humiliation unless you are that one person that
wins and that would not bring out the best.
Now I'd be like,
well on,
especially because I was 26 years old by the time I'd done a the challenge and
they were like sit on a block of ice and a bikini for two hours for a free bike.
And I was like,
listen motherfuckers,
I got $100 I can go buy a bike.
Yeah,
I'm too old for this.
When you're 21 they take your pills and they're like,
jump off a cliff to earn $100.
Like okay,
I can,
I got to eat today.
It's a different,
yeah.
Well a
change to where the formula became let's get people crazy people and,
and hammered.
Yeah.
So it just became about,
cause I went was I went with you,
they asked you to go to some while I was friends with Chris of breakout was
telling me like a dinner or something.
Yeah.
And I saw these,
the,
the cameras and I was like,
I started,
I mean I got like real anxiety.
I was like,
I don't want to be a part of this at all.
And then I noticed that I was like,
I'm just going to literally stand in the background,
not be a part of this that,
you know,
they were giving everyone drinks and then somebody would have a few drinks come
over and be like,
Hey,
what is your fucking problem?
Exactly.
Like out of nowhere.
And that was the fuel for the conversation in the show.
And I was like,
this is contrived and fueled by alcohol.
It's like,
I don't like it.
I like,
if you're clever enough,
you don't need to rely on this,
you know,
to make entertainment that's so base level.
Like,
yeah,
I prefer if I'm going to be on TV,
let's make it entertaining and not just gross.
Sure.
Yeah.
Look at these,
look at this thing.
Debt.
That's right.
They were smaller back then.
They were maybe c pluses.
I'm 21 and I was so skinny and I had those huge knockers.
Yeah,
meet.
We met doing standup out here in la like a million years ago.
Years ago.
We've been together for like 14 years.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that other dog.
Damn,
that was a far jump there.
That was 50 feet.
No,
25 feet and then 50 it was really scary actually.
They don't let you do this anymore at Wyoming for sure.
Oh yeah.
Was the night
and we used to sign release forms before every mission before we knew what they
were and it was to release the company from any liability.
And I was wrestling crocodiles,
jumping off a cliff and back then they didn't give a good dude,
whatever you,
are you really that brave or was it because you were on TV and you were like,
well I can't give up.
No,
I didn't want him to be on road rules.
I asked to be on the real world.
I was like,
put me in a house for five months.
I want to smoke some cigarettes.
I want to eat.
I want to like talk to people.
I don't want to do anything.
And that's why they're like,
you're going to go on road rules.
And I was like,
is it free travel?
Okay.
I was living in a closet in San Francisco because rent was so expensive in the
90s,
and I just wanted out.
So what's the most ridiculous request you've had from a charter guest?
Yeah,
I can ask this question all the time and as I should have a good solid answer,
but it turns out nothing's that ridiculous to me because it's all so ridiculous.
But I'll give some examples like I'm just to sensitize.
Uh,
I had a two week charter on,
they were Russians again and uh,
I know they have a lot of long island,
right?
Yeah.
And also duck cock Molotov cocktails.
And so they brought on their fi,
their wives and their children for the first week and we get to know them and
where I making for the babies.
Okay.
By now the wives and children are leaving and we're in Saint Martin and
literally I see the private chat with the mothers and the children flying over
us.
Well,
s gaggle of hookers or walking on board.
Hi.
And it's hard for us because we just got to know your children and your wives
and now we have to be like,
and so they were up in the Jacuzzi having a good time and I asked my stewardess
came down,
she's like,
I'm not going up there anymore.
And I was like,
why should,
well they offer something in their hand or mouth anyway,
so there's not like there's anything I could give them.
I know.
That's awesome.
Yeah,
it was funny.
That's brutal though,
man.
Fish.
Do you guys,
when,
when you have clients like that or,
or maybe just in general,
is there a bunch of nondisclosures that these people make you sign it?
I mean,
you would think so.
I don't think they expected that their stewardess was going to go on a reality
show.
It's Phil other secrets podcast when the celebs come on.
Um,
yeah,
there's huge nondisclosures for like Jay Z and Beyonce.
They always rent a yacht in the wintertime and their crew is like sworn to
secrecy.
I worked on one yacht,
I had to sign an NDA.
Was this she?
She's a music producer.
Um,
and she has a lot of celebrities come on.
Like Kim and Kanye came on start.
Jones came on.
Well that's not really the same,
but she only brings on famous people.
Yeah,
we had to sign to sign your contract.
You have to say,
I won't say anything.
And on the show,
by the way,
when it's tip time,
the tips are always cash.
Sometimes you'll get a wire.
But yeah,
somebody asked me like,
do they travel?
How much cash?
And I'm like,
I guess they do.
That's wild.
All 50 grand I just brought with me.
But they're going on a private jet so that doesn't really matter.
I guess you're not going to the ATM.
Sure.
And the bug.
We'll get some tip money.
Philly has a limit.
We've got to do it four more times.
Yeah.
Well what if this guy were like a charter guest?
Would you,
what would you do for him?
You know what God's love to fuck and fuck gook that's draw hot black guy.
And you want to fuck me at 2195 if you want to move in,
you can move up.
But you got to fuck the how many I need to be fucked a lot,
man.
Ever free food,
free rent and everything else,
man.
He has a deal man.
Well I first of all,
I like to know that I can cuss on here cause I did and now I'm up
first.
I obviously make him a dick blanket
every day and then I would make sure we went somewhere that had what he was
looking for.
It sounds to me like I wouldn't be having to serve him too much if I found,
you know?
Yeah,
you keep busy.
Yeah.
So Baby Caribbean,
you would stay there for sure.
100% yeah.
Hey,
what do you think?
Cause I'm so,
I,
I dunno,
I can't imagine doing your job.
I can't imagine being nice to shit bird people.
Like how,
what kind of personality type is drawn to this work?
You think honestly on real yachts and aren't being filmed on TV that guests
don't really want to talk to you that much.
There's there to chill out,
relax,
take a nap.
And the Russians definitely don't want you to talk to them like no,
no,
no.
They want to keep it separate.
So do they speak English?
Most of the ones that come here,
they do and they're nice enough,
but they're not there to talk to us.
They're like,
I would want my coffee and they won't even say thank you half the time,
which is fine cause you just drop it off,
go back to the crew mess and whatever.
It's the guests that want to talk.
It's almost,
that's more work.
It's like,
yeah hmm.
We could have this fake conversation but also I've got a bunch of shit to do for
you.
So it's like,
I don't love chatting with the guests that are nice.
I,
I like Russian asshole.
You know.
I know what you're getting.
That guy.
Yeah,
that guy.
That way.
Cause you know what you're getting though to the Russian guys direct.
There's no like,
yeah,
here's what I want and I don't want any bullshit.
I mean I've worked for lovely American people and that's great too.
Um,
I guess the worst ones are the ones that want to party,
party,
party.
And usually it's people who have inherited their money that are the worst
because most 99% of yacht owners are self made.
And so they're busy,
they're still working and they're like,
you know,
they're chilling out,
their families relaxing.
But the businessman,
the money maker he used,
he's still working,
but it's the ones that inherit their money.
They don't appreciate anything.
It's just,
that's a nightmare.
So what happens like the morning after the hookers,
you guys got to put on a nice face.
Good morning.
Uh,
yeah.
And that's real difficult when you go into to make their bed and it looks like a
murder snuff film because like there's like hand prints and sheets are off the
bed and what I hope is lotion on the glass door,
but I don't know.
And you're just like on your walkie talkie,
we're gonna need a stick at least six foot long and a lot of gloves.
Oh yeah,
it gets gross.
Yeah.
Cause I've heard the story of the toilets are gnarly too,
right?
You,
I'm sure you've seen,
well you can't really put much down at,
but then when they get drunk,
they forget that.
So that's not a good day for the engineers.
But um,
yeah.
And also they drink so much and I think when you're on a yacht in international
waters,
you're like,
there are no laws here.
Let's get crazy.
Nobody could see me.
We're in the middle of the ocean.
So they just,
it's the worst behavior.
Yeah.
So I got to get this.
Oh yeah,
we got to do this,
man.
Yeah,
come on.
So we 200 grand for a week.
No,
no,
no.
That's the minimum.
We haven't paid for our food,
our tip fuel.
None of it yet.
So as captain leave,
if we can work something out.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh my gosh.
Yeah.
Just ask him for like an 80% break on it.
I'll see what I can do.
Okay.
Thank you.
It's a banana.
So what are you doing now?
So you got Bravo.
Yeah,
you got your book out.
Where can people get your book?
It's on Amazon and it's called lucky.
Charming and I recorded the audio book,
which quite frankly I love an audio book.
You can like listen to it while you're cleaning and drinking wine.
Yeah.
Drinking wine and then not so much cleaning.
And where do people get that one that's going to be available on Amazon as well?
I've recorded it and I just haven't published it yet.
Very.
Yeah,
but the show's so good this season.
It's my favorite season of below deck.
It's the biggest boat,
the best location,
the best crew.
They're crazy and experience.
And it's Tuesdays at nine on Bravo guys.
Get on at Dewa.
We do.
I mean you can,
you can obviously go Tuesdays.
Isn't that Bravo?
We just buy the season pass.
We buy the show so that we don't have to watch commercials.
That is commitment.
I appreciate it.
Yeah,
we buy the season pass immediately.
Um,
or yeah,
or you can go on the Bravo App.
I'm sure you can stream it there too.
But this has been an absolute thrill for us.
Me Too.
Thank you so much.
Oh so excited.
Can't wait to watch more below deck.
I hope you guys keep making 15 more seasons of it,
and,
um,
thank you.
Thank you again for coming.
Thank you for having me.
Wow.
Oh,
sure.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
Wow.
Harris.